Hello listener, my name is Jason Bateman. I am one of three hosts on Smart List. The other two are late, as they are one to do. I am prompt and I am also a fan of stone fruit. You might not know what stone fruit is, but it is a peach, a plum, a cherry, a nectarine. Things with stones in the middle of it. And right now, listener, they're glorious
听众朋友们，大家好，我是杰森·贝特曼。我是《聪明笨蛋》节目的三位主持人之一。另外两位又迟到了，他们一贯如此。我很准时，而且我也很喜欢核果。你们可能不知道什么是核果，但它其实就是桃子、李子、樱桃、油桃。也就是中间有核的水果。听众朋友们，现在正是它们最好吃的时候，
and they are well in stock at your local market. You think I'm kidding, but the serenity in my voice right now is prompted by the incredible fleshy stone fruits I've had in the last half hour. Welcome to Smart List. Smart, less, smart, less, smart, less. Go ahead, John. I was just gonna ask you, so you listen to Italian rap.
而且你家附近的市场上到处都是。你们以为我在开玩笑，但我现在语气中的这份平静，全因我过去半小时里吃到了那些多汁美味的核果。欢迎收听《聪明笨蛋》。聪明，笨，聪明，笨，聪明，笨。说吧，约翰。我刚想问你，所以你平时会听意大利说唱。
Sure. And that's like a real thing. Yeah, I listened to Italian rap. I listened to French rap. Well, because you can understand French, but I don't think you speak Italian. I don't speak Italian. I wish I did.
当然。这可不是随便说说的。对，我听意大利说唱。我也听法国说唱。好吧，因为你能听懂法语，但我觉得你不会说意大利语。我不会说意大利语。我希望我会。
So why, what's the draw? The draw is it's about a lifestyle. Well, hip hop, no matter where it is, is about a lifestyle, Sean, so cool it. And I can tell by the way you look that you really, you understand that. Put it this way, you see me on a scooter in downtown Naples rolling with my crew.
那为什么，吸引你的点是什么？吸引我的点在于它是一种生活方式。好吧，西恩，不管在哪儿，嘻哈音乐讲究的都是生活方式，所以冷静点。我从你的外表就能看出，你是真的，你很懂这个。这么跟你说吧，你看到我骑着一帮兄弟在拿坡里市中心的一辆踏板车上兜风。
Can I ask you an honest question? Ask me anything you want. My hair, my hat. I always wear a hat. No, it was about me. Oh, sorry. How would I look with a neck tattoo? To me, no different than you look now.
我能问你个实话吗？你想问什么都行。我的头发，我的帽子。我总是戴着帽子。不，我是想问我。哦，不好意思。我要是弄个颈部刺青会怎么样？在我看来，跟你现在没什么两样。
No different. Jason, we're rolling. Sorry, sorry, that was a long walk. Oh, I guess so, from one wing to the other. We're rolling. We're rolling right now. You're on the show right now, Jason. Yeah, you're a little late, Jason.
一模一样。杰森，我们在录音了。抱歉，抱歉，刚才铺垫得有点久。哦，也是，从大厅的一头走到另一头嘛。我们在录音了。我们现在正在录音。杰森，你现在在节目里呢。对，你有点迟到了，杰森。
Well, do you ever wear like long sleeve shirts? You're always in a T-shirt, always every 20,000. Well, I'm in a climate-controlled house. Do you not have climate? What's going on? Are you just exposed to the elements? We can be in a world with,
对了，你穿过长袖衬衫吗？你总是穿T恤，每两万年都这样。好吧，我在恒温的房子里。难道你那里没有恒温设备吗？怎么回事？难道你直接暴露在大自然里吗？我们可以生活在一个，
Thoreau could be the third leg on this tripod and we'd have to deal with no sleeves at all. Can you imagine? Jason, are you having a coffee? Is that what your beverage is? Yeah, and I think it's a little late for the coffee. I get more irritable than usual. The later I drink coffee, but I'm gonna try it.
梭罗都能成为这个三脚架的第三条腿，而我们却连袖子都不用穿的世界里。你能想象吗？杰森，你在喝咖啡吗？你喝的是这个吗？对，我觉得现在喝咖啡有点晚了。我喝咖啡的时间越晚，就会比平时更烦躁。但我还是想试试。
And it's late right now. I know, and I get all sweaty. Well, we have a guest here. Wait a second, we're rolling? Yeah, we got a guest here. There's some guys. Our guest is, so I don't know, it's tough to describe our guest
而且现在已经很晚了。我知道，而且我浑身是汗。好吧，我们这里来了一位嘉宾。等一下，我们在录音吗？对，我们这里有位嘉宾。有些人在呢。我们的嘉宾是，怎么说呢，很难形容我们的嘉宾，
because this person does so many things. Our guest started on a show that might be close to your heart. I'm not sure, a show called Hillside. Four Seasons. Hillside Blues? Four Seasons on Hillside. I think in this country it was called 15.
因为这位大咖身兼数职。我们的嘉宾是从一部可能勾起你回忆的节目出道的。我不确定，那部剧叫《山边》。四季。或是《山边蓝调》？《山边》里的四季。我想在这个国家它叫《15》。
It's one of those shows that had different names in different countries. But American person? Well, this person is a person you, is not an American person. This is a person who lives in America. But this is a person who, well, strangely enough, comes from just north of the border, where I'm from.
这是一部在不同国家有不同名字的剧。但是美国人吗？好吧，这个人，不是美国人。这是一个住在美利坚的人。但这是一个，说来奇怪，来自我老家边境以北的人。
Oh, so it's one of three people. So this person's an entrepreneur. This person is a visionary. Oh boy. Is a business visionary. He's got his hands in mobile phones. He's got his hands in the booze industry. He's now got his hands in Welsh football.
哦，那也就是三个人选之一了。所以这个人是个企业家。这个人是个富有远见的人。天哪。是个商业远见家。他涉足了移动电话行业。他涉足了酒类行业。他现在还涉足了威尔士足球。
This is a guy. Oh, for God's sake. This is Brian Reynolds. And this is your buddy, Brian. Oh my gosh. Look at him. Oh, he's gone. I hadn't even gotten to his looks yet.
这家伙。哦，看在上帝的份上。这是瑞恩·雷诺兹。这就是你的好兄弟，瑞恩。天哪。看看他。哦，他挂了。我甚至还没说到他的长相呢。
He is too hot for a podcast. It's Brian Reynolds. Oh, oh, oh. We're sleeves today, guys. Now, Ryan, in week one of this COVID baby, we call smartless. I think I sent you a text that said, listen, I know you love to do podcasts.
他帅得不适合录播客了。是瑞恩·雷诺兹。哦，哦，哦。伙计们，我们今天穿袖子衣服了。瑞恩，在这场我们称之为“聪明笨蛋”的COVID宝宝第一周时，我想我给你发过一条短信，上面写着，听说我知道你很喜欢做播客，
So we're happy to accommodate you. It was a sarcastic sort of passive-aggressive pitch that never heard back from you. Yeah, a little bit of a fucking pandemic, Bateman. But shit was going on. I was batting down the hatches. Appropriate response. Appropriate response.
所以我们很乐意配合你。那是一种讽刺式的被动攻击推销，结果从来没收到你的回复。没错，贝特曼，那时候正他妈的闹大流行。事情多着呢。我当时正忙着严阵以待呢。得体的回应。得体的回应。
By the way, I'm still hung up on hillside blues, picturing me and Dennis Frans as a couple of angsty teenagers going through puberty together. Don't skirt the issue here. So I get a no. I don't even get a no. I just get a no response. But you say yes, Tarnat.
顺便说一句，我脑子里还在琢磨《山边蓝调》，想象着我和丹尼斯·弗兰茨就像两个充满青春期烦恼的青少年一起经历青春期。别在这儿避重就轻。所以我得到了一个“不”。我甚至连“不”都没得到。我只得到了石沉大海。但你答应了，塔纳特。
You and I are so much closer to fucking will in you. Let me reset the table here. Can I reset the table? This will be quick. It better probably back up. You guys just wait. I have never been in a room, virtual or otherwise, with three people who have at many points in my life,
你和我对威尔的了解可比你深多了。让我重新摆一下桌子。我能重新摆一下桌子吗？很快就好。最好还是快点，你们都等着吧。我从来没有和三个人在同一个房间里（不管是虚拟的还是现实的）待过，在我的生命中，
caused me to fall over, weeping with laughter. This is one of the, this is a moment. We're after a great start. Each one of you guys. Take your time. That's very nice. Have made a adult diaper requisite wardrobe for me to watch. Go around the table.
他们曾多次让我笑得前仰后合，泪流满面。这是其中一个，这是一个时刻。我们开局很棒。你们每个人。慢慢来。这太好了。都让我需要准备好成人纸尿裤才能看。环顾桌子四周。
Go around the table. Go around visually. Guys, no, truly. Let him finish. Bateman was the first person when I moved to Los Angeles that was kind to me that I found that was kind. I was 18 years old. And I had just, just hairless, freshly waxed eyebrows
环顾桌子四周。从视觉上环顾四周。伙计们，不，真的。让他说完。当我搬到洛杉矶时，贝特曼是我遇到的第一个对我好的人。我当时18岁。我刚刚，刚刚剃光了毫毛，修得精致的眉毛，
were exquisite and got to Los Angeles. I ended up in this manager's office that would never in a million years take me. But in walks, Jason Bateman, and just out of nowhere, asked me where I'm from, what I'm doing here. I think I said, Hey friend. And I started with, Hey friend. He could see my soul visibly exiting my body.
然后来到了洛杉矶。我最后来到了这个经理的办公室，他们原本有一百万个理由不会录用我。但是杰森·贝特曼走了进来，莫名其妙地问我来自哪里，在这里做什么。我想我当时说，嘿，朋友。我是从“嘿，朋友”开始的。他能看出我的灵魂明显已经出窍了。
He always talks to wandering teens. That's always been one of his. It really is the hallmark of a truly dynamic predator. Hey, hairless, vulnerable, innocent looking friend. Come this way. What brings you to the office? You look like you could use a ride. But he was, no, he did not,
他总是跟流浪的青少年搭话。这一直是他的特色之一。这确实是一个真正充满活力的大灰狼的标志。嘿，没毛的、脆弱的、看起来很无辜的朋友。往这边走。是什么风把你吹到办公室来的？你看上去需要搭便车。但他并没有，
he did not drive a panel van nor did he offer me any candy whatsoever. So Bateman was kind to you. So Bateman spoke to you and you knew him at that point from all is from the teens. Of course, Jason Bateman. Is Jason Bateman. Ryan, Ryan, did you move out here cold?
他既没有开着厢式货车，也没有给我任何糖果。所以贝特曼对你很好。所以贝特曼跟你说过话，那时你从青少年时期就认识他了。当然，杰森·贝特曼就是杰森·贝特曼。瑞恩，瑞恩，你当时是孤身一人搬到这里的吗？
I mean, did you, did you have a reason to move out or did you just move out to be an actor? He was coming off hillside, otherwise known as 15. Coming off hillside blues. Yeah, wait, wait, wait, what is hillside and where, what is the game? Me and Lawrence Pressman, you know, smashing it together.
我是说，你，你是为了什么原因搬出来的，还是单纯为了当演员才搬出来的？他当时刚拍完《山边》，也就是大家知道的《15》。刚拍完《山边蓝调》。等等，等等，等等，什么是《山边》，在哪里，这到底是什么情况？我和劳伦斯·普雷斯曼，你知道的，合作得非常默契。
Just throwing out all the fun, going deep cuts on the, on the. Now listen, Ryan, do you remember the first time we met? I remember very well. The first time we met in person. Do you remember? Start to nod politely. Where was that?
把所有有趣的东西都抛出来，深入挖掘那些。现在听着，瑞恩，你还记得我们第一次见面吗？我记得很清楚。我们第一次线下见面。你还记得吗？开始礼貌地点头。那是在哪儿？
It was at a gym. Oh, in Equinox and Santa Monica. Thank you very much. Equinox and Santa Monica. Yep. And you know what my thought was? I was in there just, I was moving some weight around. And obviously I'm no stranger to a gym
那是在一家健身房。哦，在圣莫尼卡的Equinox。非常感谢。圣莫尼卡的Equinox。没错。你知道我当时的想法是什么吗？我当时就在那儿，我正在举铁。很显然，我对健身并不陌生，
and we don't need to get into that. I'll say. Yeah. Move some weight around. Why don't you shut the hell up? So I'm in there and I'm feeling, I'm feeling kind of good about myself. Sure you are.
我们不需要细谈这个。我得说。是的。举了点铁。你丫怎么不闭嘴呢？所以我当时在那儿，我觉得，我对自己感觉挺好。你当然觉得好。
And old Brian Reynolds as Dax likes to call him to his face, which always makes me laugh because it's just not funny. And I do it too. Ryan comes in and I'm like, this motherfucker is so handsome and he's so strong and I look like it. I like pretty quickly like,
而老布莱恩·雷诺兹——正如达克斯喜欢当面叫的那样，这总是让我发笑，因为一点都不好笑。我也这么叫。瑞恩进来了，我在想，这混蛋怎么这么帅，力气又这么大，而我看起来。我很快就觉得，
I'm gonna put these 20s down and I'm just gonna leave. He was actually only in ankle weights. Will was wearing nothing but ankle weights. But Ryan, what about my question? Did you, did you move to LA to be, what was my question? Did you actually move because you had an offer for something or did you move to start a career here?
我要把这二十磅的哑铃放下，然后马上离开。他其实只绑了脚踝沙袋。威尔当时只绑了脚踝沙袋。但是瑞恩，我的问题呢？你是，你是为了，我有问题吗？你搬过来是因为收到了某个工作邀约，还是为了在这里开启一番事业？
No, I mean, I was working at Safeway grocery store at the time in Vancouver. I didn't even quit. I just, I just left. Went on break. I'd gone to college. I'm not making this up for 45 minutes. I walked in and I just went, nope.
没有，我是说，我当时在温哥华的西夫韦（Safeway）杂货店工作。我甚至都没辞职。我只是，我只是走了。去休息了。我去上大学了。我没有编造这个，就45分钟。我走进去然后就想，不。
And I went right back, pulled one more all night shift at Safeway and then the next day just got in my car and drove to Los Angeles. What department at Safeway? Yeah, exactly. Will you check out or will you box boy or? No, I did train as a cashier, but I was actually stocking shelves midnight to eight AM.
然后我又回去了，在西夫韦又值了一个通宵班，第二天就直接上车开去了洛杉矶。你在西夫韦哪个部门？是的，正好。你是收银员还是理货员？不，我确实接受过收银培训，但实际上我是从半夜理货到早上八点。
I was working on a graveyard shift. Yeah. Facing out all the growth. So everything is perfectly smooth and flat. Yeah. Make it. Do you ever like just open a box of cereal and just house it when nobody was looking?
我上的是夜班。对。把所有的货都理到最前面。这样一切都完美平整。对。弄好。你有没有过那种趁四下无人，偷偷撕开一盒麦片直接干掉的时候？
No, most of the time it's food fights. I mean, some of the people I worked with at Safeway, there's a graveyard shift at Safeway at 25th and Oak. They know who they are. Some of the funniest human beings. I bet. That I've ever been around. Some big laughs.
没有，大部分时候都是食物大战。我是说，我在西夫韦共事过的一些人，第25街和奥克街的西夫韦夜班员工。他们知道自己是谁。他们是我见过最搞笑的人。我敢说。我这辈子遇到过的人里。笑得前仰后合。
I bet you had some huge laughs. I'm not joking. Are you still friends with any of your coworkers there? I don't keep in touch with men. I kept friends with a lot of people that I went to high school with, but like that was an odd group because we only saw each other
我敢说你们肯定笑得很大声。我没开玩笑。你现在还和那里的同事保持联系吗？我跟他们没有联系。我跟很多高中同学保持着联系，但那群人挺奇怪的，因为我们只在漆黑的深夜里才能见到彼此。
in the pitch black midnight hours. All coked up and stacking. Oh God, yeah. All glued up. Stacking and pricing. So are you really still friends with, even if you're friends with five friends from high school, I admire that.
全嗑嗨了在那儿理货。天哪，是的。全兴奋着呢。理货和标价。所以你真的还跟，哪怕你跟高中时的五个朋友保持联系，我也很佩服这一点。
I wish I was better at that. I'm still in touch with my high school girlfriend who's now married with three kids. I'm in touch with one of my best friends, Peter Zurbinos, that I went to school with my whole life since Little League, I basically know him. Ryan, Ryan, this is, be honest, and she won't hear this, high school girlfriend.
我希望自己也能做得更好。我还跟我的高中女友保持着联系，她现在已经结婚并有三个孩子了。我跟我的挚友之一彼得·祖比诺斯还有联系，我们从小一起上学，从少儿棒球联盟起就认识了，基本上很早就认识他了。瑞恩，瑞恩，说实话，而且她不会听到这个，就是高中女友。
How hard is she kicking herself right now? I mean, do you think it's... I think she married a surgeon. She's doing all right. Oh, she married, okay. And she herself is a prolific educator. She's doing really well. She's really barely.
她现在肠子悔青的程度有多大？我是说，你觉得……我觉得她嫁给了一个外科医生。她现在过得挺好。哦，她嫁给，好吧。她自己也是一位多产的教育工作者。她过得真不错。她真的几乎。
Does the surgeon have a back on him like you do? My God, yes. That guy had thighs like Earl Campbell. I mean, he was just an absolute shredder on the football field. Did he steal her from you? No, he did not. No, we were together in 10th grade
那个外科医生身材也像你那样有一块块肌肉吗？天哪，是的。那家伙的大腿简直就像厄尔·坎贝尔。我是说，他在橄榄球场上绝对是个狠角色。是他从你手里把她抢走的吗？不，不是的。没有，我们在高一时在一起，
and broke up in 11th grade. And they got together after that. Relationships run hot in 10th. Right, sure do. Yeah, sure do. I was too busy working with Dennis Friends. Yeah. Wait, when you got here,
高二时分的手。他们是之后才在一起的。高中的恋情总是来得快去得也快。确实如此。对，确实如此。我当时忙着跟丹尼斯·弗兰茨合作呢。对。等等，当你来到这里时，
like tell us because I love little origin stories like from actors because I did the same thing. I just got in my car. I've never even been here before. You never driven a car. Yeah, hang on a second. What kind of car did you rock out here from? A Toyota Corolla.
跟我们讲讲，因为我很喜欢演员们的微小背景故事，就像我经历过的一样。我也是直接上了车。我甚至从来没来过这里。你从来没开过车。等一下。你当时开着什么车来这儿的？一辆丰田卡罗拉。
A Toyota Corolla. And let me tell you something really quick story. When I got the pilot of Will and Grace, they had a kickoff dinner and I drove my Corolla and the only place that you could park it was to valet at this one restaurant. And I was so embarrassed because the window was out, the hubcap was missing.
一辆丰田卡罗拉。我跟你们讲个超短的故事。当我拿到《威尔和格蕾丝》试播集时，他们办了一场开机晚宴，我开着我的卡罗拉去，唯一能停车的地方就是那家餐厅的代客泊车处。我当时尴尬极了，因为车窗掉了，轮毂盖也不见了。
All that was disgusting. The car was dense everywhere and I made sure I got there before everybody else. I went in and had a dinner with the cast of Will and Grace and Jimmy Burroughs and everybody. And I'm so embarrassed. I didn't want them to see me get the valet when I got out.
所有地方都恶心死了。车身到处都是凹痕，我确保自己比所有人都先到。我进去和《威尔和格蕾丝》的演员阵容以及吉米·伯劳斯他们一起吃了晚饭。我太尴尬了。我不想让他们看到我下车时去叫代客泊车。
So I left early. I was like, guys, I'm sorry, I gotta get up early. Bye. I got up to the valet. Still waiting for my car. And one by one is taking forever. One by one, everybody else comes out. Now we're all standing in a line
所以我提前走了。我说，伙计们，抱歉，我得早起。拜拜。我走到代客泊车那儿。还在等我的车。车子一辆接一辆，慢得要命。一个接一个，其他人也都出来了。现在我们都排成一排，
and my fucking car pulls up, first one. And I go, what did you do to my car? Or run, run, run, run. First of all, it wasn't a Corolla. It was not a Toyota Corolla. Sean, how quickly were you trying to pull off your co-exist bumper? Cause you've always,
结果我那辆破车开过来了，而且是第一个。我说，你们对我车做了什么？快跑，跑，跑，跑。首先，那不是卡罗拉。那根本不是丰田卡罗拉。西恩，你当时有多急着想把你的“共存”车贴撕下来？因为你一直，
Yeah, right. Cause you believe co-exist. I drew, I drove a similar sensible sedan for years. Even after I had a TV show, I remember I kept my little Nissan Sentra and was just covered in Ross the hubca. Same thing. It was, it wasn't even a car.
没错。因为你相信共存。我开过多年类似的实用型轿车。即使我有了电视节目，我记得我还留着我那辆满是罗斯轮毂盖的小日产森特拉。同样的情况。那甚至不能算是一辆车，
It was just like millions of wasps fucking. Like this car was just like absolute like danger to two of the bottom was out. And you just moved it with your feet, like Fred Flynn's down. So Ryan, so you move here and you had done a show. You've done a sort of like a YA show for a few years. And that was like your first big kind of-
那简直就像几百万只黄蜂在狂欢。这辆车绝对是个移动危险源，底盘都快掉了。你只能像弗雷德·弗林斯通那样用脚蹬着往前走。所以瑞恩，你搬到这里来的时候，你已经演过一个节目了。你演过几年青少年剧。那可以说是你的第一部大制作——
That's young adult for Wisconsin. Young adult. And then, and then, so you move here and then you get two guys, a girl, originally known as two guys, a girl in a pizza place. That which they dropped the pizza place. Great show. Great show.
那是威斯康星州的青少年剧。青少年剧。然后，然后，你搬到了这里，接着你接了《两男一女》，原本叫《两男一女与比萨店》。后来他们把比萨店去掉了。好剧。好剧。
Great show. And I remember seeing you on that show. I remember auditioning for that show. I remember- Come on. Did you get it? Did you get it? Yeah, I think I did get it.
好剧。我记得在那部剧里看过你。我记得我还去试镜过那部剧。我记得——
Yeah. I think we did. I forget how many seasons. Well, Ryan, I'll tell you. I think four and a half seasons ago. Yeah, we did like four seasons ago. But Ryan, I remember how, and this is no joke, how funny you were.
别说了。你拿下了吗？你拿下了吗？对，我想我确实拿下了。对。我想我们拿下了。我忘了有多少季了。好吧，瑞恩，我告诉你。我想那是四年半前。对，我们大概拍了四季吧。但瑞恩，我记得当时，这不是开玩笑，你有多搞笑。
It was undeniable. You're such a funny- I watched that show all the time. I thought you were hilarious. The timing is like a Swiss watch. His timing is impeccable. Like a surgeon. Here's what I want to know, Ryan.
那是无可否认的。你是个那么有趣的人——我经常看那部剧。我觉得你太搞笑了。你的节奏就像瑞士手表一样精准。他的节奏无可挑剔。就像外科医生一样。这是我想知道的，瑞恩。
And the reason I bring this up is this. Because you've gone on, you've had, I think, a super interesting career. And I think that you've always, no matter what, you're always good in everything you do. And everybody does things that sometimes they don't, you know, I remember somebody describing a movie, a bad movie.
我提起这个的原因是这样的。因为你一路走来，拥有了一段，我认为超级有趣的职业生涯。而且我觉得你无论如何，在做的每件事里总是表现得很出色。每个人有时都会做一些他们自己也说不清的事，我记得有人形容过一部电影，一部烂电影。
You're like, well, I thought we were going over here. Oh, we're going over here. There are certain things that are out of your control. What you can control is you're always really, really good. And I've always thought you were super funny. Like Bayman said, your timing is incredible. I feel like you are depriving the world of more just pure comedy.
你就想，好吧，我以为我们要去这边。哦，我们要去那边。有些事情是超出你控制的。你能控制的是你总是表现得非常非常棒。我一直觉得你超级搞笑。就像贝特曼说的，你的节奏感不可思议。我觉得你剥夺了世人看到你更多纯喜剧演出的机会。
Look, I love seeing you in the action stuff. I love seeing you kick ass. And you do bring humor to those parts. But fuck man, you could absolutely crush pure comedy. I think you're so fucking funny. Where he's going with this is, please do another sitcom is where the question is. Well, I would love to do another sitcom.
听着，我喜欢看你演动作戏。我喜欢看你大杀四方。你在那些角色里确实融入了幽默。但该死的，你绝对能驾驭纯喜剧。我觉得你太他妈搞笑了。他这话的意思是，请再拍一部情景喜剧吧，问题就在这儿。好吧，我很乐意再拍一部情景喜剧。
Best job I've ever had in my life. I know everyone here has had their, you know, it really is the greatest job in the world. Absolutely. Reasonable hours, live audience, you know, fun. You get to improv. And the reason I moved to answer Sean's question was to move to Los Angeles was to join the Groundlings,
这是我一生中做过的最好的工作。我知道这里的每个人都有过他们的，你知道的，这真的是世界上最棒的工作。绝对的。合理的工作时间，现场观众，你知道，很有趣。你还能即兴发挥。我搬来洛杉矶的初衷，是为了回答西恩的问题，是为了加入The Groundlings剧团，
which as a, you know, 18 year old moron, I thought I could just show up there and they would put me on the stage. And the Groundlings is like second city. It's an improv kind of trip. We're a Saturday night live. Are you telling that to Ryan? He moved here to go away.
作为一个，你知道的，18岁的笨蛋，我以为我只要出现在那里，他们就会让我上台。The Groundlings就像Second City一样。是一个即兴喜剧的地方。就像《周六夜现场》。你是在跟瑞恩说这个吗？他是为了去加入这个才搬过来的——
No, I'm telling it to him. Why are you explaining it to him? Did you get into Groundlings? No, they were like, of course not. They were like, he got to get in his class. You can't, I was like, I don't have enough money to sit in the class. I need to make some dough.
不，我是说给他听的。你为什么向他解释这个？你进The Groundlings了吗？没有，他们当时的反应是，当然没有。他们的反应是，你得先上他的课。你不能，我当时想，我没有足够的钱去上课。我得赚点面包。
So you're in the class at Groundlings. How are you, what's your day job? Did you go to Albertsons and Vaughns and say, hey, I got a pretty good tenure. Pretty swell CV going here, guys. I know how to work a manual forklift like no, I know how to close a wound with crazy glue like no one else. Did you, what was your first day job out here?
所以你在The Groundlings上课时，你的日常工作是什么？你有没有去Albertsons和Vaughns超市说，嘿，我履历挺丰富的。我有份相当不错的简历，伙计们。我知道怎么开手动叉车，我知道怎么用强力胶缝合伤口，无人能及。你，你在这里的第一份日常工作是什么？
I had no day job because I had no work permit. So I couldn't just walk into any place and Will knows this, he can't just walk. So you have to, you need a work permit. So actually I went looking for an agent to see if I could get sent out on a couple of auditions and maybe that way they would sponsor me. And that's when you met Teen Wolf too?
我没有日常工作，因为我没有工作签证。所以我不能随便走进任何地方，威尔也知道，他不能随便走进去。所以你必须得有工作签证。实际上，我是去找经纪人，看能不能被派去试镜几次，也许通过这种方式他们会为我担保。然后你就在那儿遇到了《狼少年2》？
Well, that's exactly when I met Teen Wolf too. Come on, really? That was it? I know I'd just been rejected from the Groundlings and the next day I met you. And then when I met Jason, Did he got hit on by a weirdo? No, he saw the look of pure unadulterated panic in my face.
好吧，那正是我遇到《狼少年2》的时候。得了吧，真的吗？就是这样？我知道我刚被The Groundlings拒绝，第二天就遇到了你。然后当我遇到杰森时，他被一个怪胎搭讪了？没有，他看到了我脸上那种纯粹、毫无掩饰的恐慌表情。
And he asked whoever it was at that management company, my number and left me a voice. This is back when you had answering machines. He left me an answering machine message. Just saying, hey, if you ever need anything, here's my number. I know you saw you. Are you serious?
他向那个经纪公司的某个人要了我的电话号码，并给我留了言。那是你们还在用答录机的年代。他在我的答录机里留了一条言。只是说，嘿，如果你需要任何帮助，这是我的电话号码。我知道我看到你了。你是认真的吗？
Is that true? I could get arrested for that nowadays. That is a random act of kindness right there. That sounds nice. I'm like anything else. Jason. But I've known this guy for a long time and this is something he does though.
这是真的吗？现在我可能会因此被捕。这简直是一场随机的善举。听起来真不错。我跟其他人没什么两样。杰森。但我认识这家伙很长时间了，这就是他会做的事。
He doesn't like to admit it or talk about it but Jason Bateman has got a wake of decades of random acts of kindness. Oh no, no, no. He has such a squishy center to him. And Ryan, I told this, what was it a couple of months ago, Sean, when I hurt my back and Jason showed up with like stuff for my, came to the house,
他不喜欢承认或谈论它，但杰森·贝特曼有一连串长达几十年的随机善举。哦，不，不，不。他的内心其实非常柔软。瑞恩，几个月前我跟西恩说过这个，当时我背受伤了，杰森带着东西出现在我家里，
just showed up unannounced. And he's got like stuff for my back and all this kind of, and very, very sweet. So that doesn't surprise me. Does freak me out a little. Freaks you out when I said, but the deal is I need to apply it. I'd like to.
就这么不请自来地出现了。他带了治我背伤的东西以及诸如此类的东西，非常非常贴心。所以这并不让我意外。确实让我有点吓一跳。我说这话时你吓了一跳，但重点是我需要用它。我很乐意。
This is the back pad. I have like 25 things aching on me right now and wrong with my body and Jason sent over Nia Sporen, but not in person. Wow. And a bill, an invoice. How is your shoulder, Sean? I heard you have a rotten shoulder.
这是护腰垫。我现在身上有大约25个地方都在酸痛，身体到处都有毛病，杰森派来了尼娅·斯波恩，不过不是本人。哇。还有一张账单，发票。你的肩膀怎么样，西恩？我听说你肩膀烂了。
I do. How do you know that? I listen to the podcast. Oh yeah. I have a bad shoulder. I don't respond to Bateman's text about it, but I listen to it. Yeah.
确实。你怎么知道的？我听了播客。哦，对。我肩膀不好。我没有回复贝特曼关于这事的短信，但我听了。对。
What about, now what about speaking to the pot? What about McLeaney and you owning a, I'll say it, football team. Soccer. Football club. A Welsh football club. Welsh, sorry, Welsh. And you're doing, and you're going to do,
那关于，现在谈谈播客的事？关于麦克尔尼和你拥有一个——我要说出来了——足球队。英式足球。足球俱乐部。一个威尔士足球俱乐部。威尔士，抱歉，威尔士。你们正在拍，你们打算拍，
you're going to do a two year documentary, like following you guys around the trials and tribulations of propping this team up to the next level. Yes. To a certain degree. Yeah. It's not so much about, we're not really centered in it as much.
你们打算拍一部为期两年的纪录片，记录你们带着这支球队一路过关斩将提升到新水平的艰难历程。某种程度上是这样的。对。这倒不是说，我们并不是绝对的核心。
I mean, we're in it, but it's really about this community in this town. Yeah. You know, there's sort of what I found interesting about this particular type of football team is that they're inextricably linked with the community. So when the football team is suffering, so is the community.
我的意思是，我们在里面，但重点其实是这个社区和这个镇子。对。你知道，我发现这种特定类型的足球俱乐部最有趣的地方在于，它们与社区有着密不可分的联系。所以当足球俱乐部陷入困境时，社区也是如此。
The community is suffering, so is the football team. So if you can find a way to kind of interconnect these two and raise them both up simultaneously, it's such an amazing, has amazing and a profound effect and a win-win for everybody. So we, we love the idea of, you know, sort of splitting our focus
社区陷入困境时，足球俱乐部也是如此。所以如果你能找到一种方法将这两者互联起来，让他们同时振作起来，那将会产生一种神奇的、深远的影响，对每个人来说都是双赢。所以我们，我们很喜欢这种想法，你知道的，
between community and the football club. You've seen Sunderland until I die, obviously. I think I've seen every single football documentary ever made at the football club. Yeah, same, same. I think you always need a face man and like nobody can replace your face, man. But, you know.
把我们的焦点分摊在社区和足球俱乐部之间。你显然看过《桑德兰：至死不渝》。我想我大概看过每一个拍过的足球俱乐部纪录片。对，一样，一样。我觉得你总是需要一个门面担当，没人能取代你的门面。但是，你知道的。
God, that was great. You see what he just did, guys? Thank you. Go ahead and rewind that listener. That was an A team reference as well. Just, you and Rob are gonna need somebody on the ground. And look, I've got a full-time job. All I'm saying is, imagine a guy.
天哪，太棒了。伙计们，你们看到他刚刚做了什么吗？谢谢。听众朋友们，快倒回去听一下。那也是一个《天龙特攻队》的梗。只是，你和罗伯需要在实地安排个人。听着，我有份全职工作。我只想说，想象一下有这么一个人。
We're losing you, Will. You going over a can? Yeah. Who can go in there. Imagine somebody who could inspire, who can pull up lyrics, whether they be Smash Mouth or Thumbnawumba. Or Italian rap.
我们快听不清了，威尔。你信号卡了吗？对。可以去那儿的人。想象一下，有这么一个人能够激励大家，能够随口拽出歌词，不管是“砸嘴乐队”（Smash Mouth）的还是“Thumpnawumba”的。或者意大利说唱。
Or Italian rap. You heard, oh yeah, of course. You heard me talking about an Italian rap. I love. And dren dren, by the way, sorry, why dren dren? I love, like I was saying, I love origin stories and your story when you first arrived to Los Angeles. And so talk to us about the kind of,
或者意大利说唱。你听到了，哦对了，当然。你听到我刚才在聊意大利说唱了。我喜欢。顺便说一句，抱歉，为什么说“dren dren”？我喜欢，就像我刚才说的，我喜欢起源故事，还有你刚到洛杉矶时的故事。所以跟我们聊聊那种，
when you got here and you said you got an agent, was hoping to find another couple jobs. But like, when did it start taking off? Was two girls and a guy the first kind of big thing that kind of led to other things? And when did that chip kind of turn on in your head that's like, wait a minute, I have to leverage all of this right now
当你来到这里，你说你找了个经纪人，希望能再找到几份工作。但是，这一切是什么时候开始起飞的？《两男一女》是第一件带动其他事情的大事吗？你的脑子是什么时候突然开窍的，心想等一下，我现在必须利用好这一切，
in order to create a clear mind. Two girls, you know what I mean? Hang on a second. You're conflating two separate jobs that he did. Two girls and a guy was something that he's trying to expunge. Two guys, a girl and a pizza joint. You're referencing a skin flick in Upper Saskatchewan
以便开辟一条清晰的思路？两男一女，你知道我的意思吗？等一下。你把他的两份不同工作混为一谈了。《两男一女》是他正极力想要抹掉的东西。《两男一女与比萨店》。你指的是萨斯喀彻温省北部的一部色情片，
that he's still running from. So we'll erase that from the record. Two guys and a girl. Skin flick. My mom was saying. So currently we have four, total of four guys. How many pizza places do we have? What the fuck was the question?
他至今还在逃避这个。所以我们要把它从记录中抹去。《两男一女》。色情片。我妈当时说。所以目前我们有四个人，总共四个人。我们有多少家比萨店？刚才那个问题到底是什么鬼？
Oh, the two guys, a girl and a pizza place, yeah. When you were on that show, is that when something clicked inside of you that said, you know, I have to figure this out so this doesn't go away. And it became this drive, this ambition that you have to, because an actor is only, you know, we thrive on our next job, we're always looking for our next gig.
哦，《两男一女与比萨店》，对。当你参演那部剧的时候，是不是有什么东西在你心里突然开窍了，心想，你知道的，我必须把这搞清楚，好让它不要消失。然后这就变成了你的动力，你必须具备的雄心壮志，因为演员仅仅是，你知道的，我们的下一份工作就是我们的动力，我们总是在寻找下一个演出机会。
And I know when I was on Will and Grace, I was like, okay, God, I'm on the show. I have to make sure I keep working now because that's what I've always wanted to do. I want to be an actor. So did that click in for you when you were on that show? Because you're so successful now in everything in so many different areas.
我知道当我拍《威尔和格蕾丝》的时候，我就想，天哪，我在这部剧里。我必须确保自己接下来能继续工作，因为那一直是我梦寐以求的。我想成为一名演员。所以当你拍那部剧的时候，这种感觉对你来说开窍了吗？因为你现在在那么多不同领域都取得了如此巨大的成功。
When did that start? No, I didn't, I mean, thank you, but I never had any. I was the very fortunate beneficiary of having zero expectations. So when I moved to Los Angeles, I wanted to join the Growlings. I didn't expect that I'd ever end up on a sitcom. And if I could get, I remember when I went
这一切是什么时候开始的？不，我没有，我是说，谢谢，但我从来没有。我非常幸运，是个零期望值的受益者。所以当我搬到洛杉矶时，我想加入The Groundlings。我从没指望自己最后能去演情景喜剧。如果我能，我记得当时我去
and met this little agency in Los Angeles called the Paul Conor Agency. Oh yeah. I said, if you just send me out on five auditions, I swear to God, I will get one. Five sitcoms, I said. And they said, okay, sure. And I was just bluffing.
在洛杉矶拜访了一家叫保罗·康纳的小型经纪公司。哦，对。我说，如果你只把我派去试镜五次，我向天发誓，我一定能拿下一个。我当时说的是五个情景喜剧。他们说，好吧，没问题。我当时其实是在虚张声势。
I didn't think I'd actually get one, but I ended up getting this one. Two guys go on a pizza place. And I, my highest aspiration was to play the wacky neighbor, you know, on like a, on a, what was that? What was the predecessor to the CW? It was the UPN network. UPN, yeah.
我以为自己拿不到任何一个，结果我偏偏拿下了这个：《两男一女与比萨店》。而我的最高志向，就是去演那种古怪的邻居，你知道的，在比如，在那个什么上面？CW的前身是什么？是UPN电视网。UPN，对。
I was hoping to get as the wacky neighbor on like the UPN network. That's where my expectation was. And that's still a pretty, coming from where I came from, there's a pretty high expectation, you know? So the fact that I got on that show, and it was one of the lead roles. And then I just learned so much as I went.
我当时的愿望只是希望能去UPN电视网演个古怪邻居。这就是我的期望值。从我当时的出身背景来看，这已经是一个相当高的期望值了，对吧？所以事实上我进入了那部剧，而且还是主角之一。然后我就在边拍边学的过程中学到了很多东西。
And I've always kind of maintained that sort of minimal expectation thing, which has served me really well. You know? What was your state of mind? So you do two guys, a girl, a pizza place, they dropped the pizza place. Obviously a lot of meetings went into that. They dropped that.
而且我一直保持着那种最低期望值的心态，这对我帮助太大了。你知道吗？你当时的心态是怎样的？所以你拍了《两男一女与比萨店》，他们去掉了比萨店。显然为此开了不少会。他们把比萨店去掉了。
And there's just two guys, a girl. And then, and then you, that show ends after four years, I think, is that right? Four and a half years. Four and a half years, the show ends. It initially comes out, it's a huge hit. So it's a big hit, blah, blah, blah. And then shows happen, things happen.
只剩下《两男一女》。然后，然后你，那部剧播了四年后结束了，我没记错吧？四年半。四年半，那部剧结束了。它刚开播时是个巨大的轰动。所以它是个大热门，等等等等。然后节目会有变动，事情会发生。
So then all of a sudden it's like 2000, I don't know, one or two or something when it ends, I think. I think I got that right. I've tracked your career for a long time, right? And so you find yourself, you're 2001, 2002, you're at Equinox a lot in Santa Monica, and I know, because I see you. And you're there and you do, but you kind of shift.
然后突然间就到了2000年，我不知道，可能是零一或零二年左右结束的，我想。我想我没记错。我关注你的职业生涯很久了，瑞恩！所以你会发现，2001、2002年的时候，你经常去圣莫尼卡的Equinox健身房，我知道，因为我看到过你。你就在那儿，你做了，但你转型了。
You do Van Wilder. Is that what it's called for, for Lampoon? Right, definitely worth a rewatch listener. Yeah, another movie that would like, it's not necessarily the greatest movie, but you're really good in that you get a lot of accolades for people, again, they point out, but where did you think you were headed coming off the show?
你演了《留级之王》（Van Wilder）。那是国家讽刺喜剧公司的电影吗？对，听众朋友们绝对值得重看一遍。是的，又是一部这样的电影，它未必是史上最伟大的电影，但你在里面的表现真的很棒，你也因此获得了很多人对你的赞誉，大家再次指出这一点，但你觉得自己拍完那部剧后会走向何方？
It's a very tricky time in an actor's life, as you know, when you come off a show, and kind of like what Sean is saying, you come off a show and you're like, oh shit, now what? Where, what were you thinking? Did you in your wildest dreams think, I'm gonna become this? Your Van Wildest.
如你所知，在演员的职业生涯中这是一个非常棘手的时期，当你拍完一部剧时，正如西恩所说，你拍完一部剧然后就会想，哦靠，接下来怎么办？你在想什么？你曾在大胆的梦想中想过，我会成为这样的人吗？你的《留级之王》。
Yeah, great, really nice, Sean. Thanks, man, it's great. But what was that, was it just day to day? Could you did Van Wilder, and then you did these Blade movies where people were like, oh my God, this guy's like an action star as well. Did you have a plan for any of that,
是的，太棒了，真的很好，西恩。谢谢你，伙计，这太棒了。但那是怎样的状态，是过一天算一天吗？你拍了《留级之王》，然后又拍了《刀锋战士》系列，当时人们都在想，哦天哪，这家伙居然还是个动作明星。你对这些有过任何规划吗，
or were you just, could you have imagined that you would achieve the success? You guys have plans? I don't have, I don't know. I was too dumb for a plan, but. Me too, my plan was to just keep this fucking heart beating. That was kind of it. I didn't, I mean, I had no, when I was doing movies,
还是说你只是，你能想象自己能取得这样的成功吗？你们有计划吗？我没有，我不知道。我太笨了，做不出什么计划。我也是，我的计划就是让这颗破心脏继续跳动。差不多就是这样。我没有，我是说我没有，当我拍电影的时候，
I was still looking for another TV show. Like my real focus was on my father's son, like, you know, Lunch Pale actor, like I need another, like a job that I know will last. This movie thing is stupid, you know? So yeah, I was always looking in front of the show. I was always trying to get back into sitcom. I think I still am.
我其实还在找另一部电视剧。我真正的重心就像我父亲的儿子一样，你知道的，一个朴实无华的演员，就像我需要另一个，一个我知道能长久的工作。拍电影这事儿太蠢了，你知道的？所以，是的，我一直在物色下一个节目。我总是试图重回情景喜剧。我想我到现在还是这样。
Well, but I'll bet you, I mean, you're just, you're too skilled and experienced now, and clear on, I think, where you wanna go, and what you're capable of doing, that at some point, you absorbed enough information and knowledge on a set to start to shape an appropriate and realistic kind of path for yourself. Like you're clearly enjoying being an entrepreneur,
好吧，但我敢打赌，我的意思是，你现在技巧太娴熟、经验太丰富了，而且你也十分清楚自己想去哪里、自己能胜任什么，所以在某个时刻，你在片场吸收了足够的信息和知识，从而开始为自己规划出一条合适且现实的道路。就像你显然很享受当一个企业家、
a producer, a star, a writer. So at some point, it started to crystallize a bit for you what you were capable of doing and what your opportunities might be if you really applied yourself, dedicated yourself to it, and treated yourself to being worthy of it, you know, in the best sense of the word. I think everyone here on this podcast can relate.
制片人、明星、编剧一样。所以在某个时刻，你开始逐渐明确自己能够做到什么，以及如果你真正全身心投入、奉献其中，并且认为自己配得上这一切时，你的机会可能会是什么，你知道的，用最好意义上的词来说。我想这里播客里的每个人都能感同身受。
You know, nothing good was ever made without enthusiasm. Sure. And I think that when you are a fan, like a genuine fan of so many people, and you really absorb a lot of what these masters are doing, and I consider you guys all masters as well. I just, you know, you start to want to create your own thing, you know, and I just feel like that eventually,
你知道的，没有热情就永远创造不出好东西。确实。而且我觉得当你是一个粉丝，一个真正崇拜许多人的人，并且你真正吸收了很多这些大师们在做的事情时——我也认为你们大家都是大师。我只是，你知道的，你会开始想要创造属于你自己的东西，你知道的，我只是觉得最终，
I got to a place where I would say it wasn't until my mid 30s, where I really understood that like, you can't be great at something unless you're willing to be bad at it. And it just freed me in a way that like, I don't think I'd ever experienced before. It really genuinely freed me up, and amazing things started happening.
我达到了这样一个境界：直到我三十多岁时，我才真正明白，除非你愿意接受自己的拙劣，否则你不可能在某件事上做到伟大。这种心态以一种我从未体验过的方式彻底解放了我。它真的由内而外地解放了我，然后神奇的事情就开始发生了。
I mean, a movie I've been trying to get made for 10 years, Deadpool finally gets made, and like, that changes my life, and then we build sort of on that, and then I can start a marketing company and continue to tell stories, and I just, you know, I think it's important. I will say as a compliment to you,
我是说，一部我努力了十年才得以拍成的电影——《死侍》终于拍成了，这改变了我的生活，然后我们在此基础上继续发展，接着我可以创办一家营销公司并继续讲述故事，我只是觉得，这很重要。作为对你的赞美，
and you could plug your ears if you don't want to hear it, but from working with you and knowing you, I know that that enthusiasm slash ambition comes not only from just wanting to accomplish things with your life, but it really comes from an appreciation and a respect for the people that you work with, and that you observe in this business. Like you have a clear appreciation for the opportunity
如果你不想听可以把耳朵捂起来，但从与你共事和了解你的经历来看，我知道那种热情加雄心壮志，不仅来自于想要在生活中成就一番事业的渴望，它其实更来自于对你共事过以及在这个行业里观察过的人的感激与尊重。就像你对你拥有的机会和资源，
and access that you have, and all of the work of the people around you. Like you have a very clear sense that it is teamwork, this business, it's not solo stuff, and you're just, it's really admirable how... You seem pretty optimistic. Graceful you are with people that you work with, you're just your kind leader.
以及周围所有人付出的努力有着清晰的感激之情。就像你非常清楚这个行业是团队合作，而不是单打独斗，而且你真的很令人钦佩……你看上去相当乐观。你对共事的人总是那么优雅，你是个善良的领导。
You get how hard people work around you. Well, I love working with people. I love collaborating. You got great skin. Beautiful skin. Thank you. Dewey skin, I sort of phrase it like that, but it's...
你明白周围的人有多努力。好吧，我喜欢跟人合作。我喜欢合作。你皮肤真好。皮肤真美。谢谢。水嫩的皮肤，我差不多是这么形容的，不过它……
It's very dewey. You know, as somebody like, I consider myself an optimistic person, as Downey always says, nobody wakes up in the morning happy or be himself more than you. And it's true. But you do seem like you're an optimistic guy
非常水润。你知道的，作为一个像我这样的人，我自认为是个乐观主义者，正如小唐尼（Downey）总是说的那样，没有人比你更能每天早上一醒来就开开心心或做自己了。这确实是真的。但你看起来确实是个乐观的人，
and that you do have a great sort of positive look on life. And in any encounter I've ever had with you, it's never different. If I see you doing, you're in a movie, or you're promoting something or talking, or you're talking on the street, you're the same guy, and you do exude that sort of positive energy.
而且你对生活确实有着一种极好的积极态度。在我跟你所有的交往中，从来没有例外。如果我看到你在拍电影，或者你在宣传什么东西、在交谈，或者你在街上聊天，你都是同一个人，你确实散发着那种积极的能量。
But are there things that get you... Like you must have things that sort of seep in like... What pisses you off? What pisses you off? When does it get dark? You know what pisses me off? Yeah, what pisses you off? No, no, I mean, I have a patchwork quilt
但是有没有什么事情会让你……你肯定也有那些会让你渗入负面情绪的事情，比如……什么能惹恼你？什么能惹恼你？什么时候事情会变得阴暗？你知道什么能惹恼我吗？对，什么能惹恼你？不，不，我的意思是，我有一块拼布被子
of pitch black night within me. That is, you know, I mean, of course, we all have that. It's like a... It keeps me warm at night. Yeah, you know that big hole with teeth in Star Wars? That is my soul. No one's heard from Blake for over 48 hours, guys.
我内心漆黑如墨的长夜。你知道的，我的意思是，当然，我们每个人都有那一面。就像是……它在夜里温暖着我。对，你知道《星球大战》里那个带牙齿的巨大黑洞吗？那就是我的灵魂。各位，已经有超过48小时没有人听到布莱克的任何消息了。
No, no, no, I ate her. Gently brazed, medium heat. And to that point, right, I have like a question about this kind of motivation positivity thing, and it's about the Green Lantern, because now that I'm speaking to you, you know, it's so funny. I was in Atlanta shooting the Three Stooges movie.
不，不，不，我把她吃掉了。文火慢煎，中火。说到这里，对吧，我有一个关于这种“积极心态与正能量”的问题，是关于《绿灯侠》的，因为现在我和你说话，你知道，太搞笑了。当时我在亚特兰大拍摄《三个臭皮匠》那部电影。
I go walk over to go see... With my friend Craig Villarco. Craig Villarco is hilarious. I love him. Yeah, very funny person. So I walk over to this mall on a day off to go see the Green Lantern. And when I walk into the mall
我走过去找……和我朋友克雷格·维拉尔科（Craig Villarco）一起。克雷格·维拉尔科太搞笑了。我超爱他。对，超级搞笑的人。所以在休息日，我走到商场去看《绿灯侠》。当我走进商场
to go see the Green Lantern, there's Jason Bateman and Ryan Reynolds shooting the change-up. Oh, yeah. And I walk in the middle of the... Right. Isn't that crazy? That was the FIPS, the FIPS Plaza or Lennox?
去看《绿灯侠》时，杰森·贝特曼和瑞安·雷诺兹正在那里拍摄《互换身体》。哦，对。然后我走进了……对。是不是超疯狂？那是Fips，Fips广场还是雷诺克斯？
Yeah, and we were reshooting, I think. I think you're right. And I walked right in the middle of the scene. I was like, hey, what's up, guys? And you were like, oh, God, this is it. Yeah, I do too. And I was like, oh my God, I'm going upstairs to watch your movie right now,
对，当时我们好像在补拍。我觉得你说得对。然后我直接走进了场景中央。我当时就想，嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？而你的反应是，哦，天哪，不会吧。对，我也是。我当时就说，哦，天哪，我要上楼去看你的电影了，
the Green Lantern, you're like, good luck. And I think I warned you. I said, don't do it. Don't do it. Save your tickets, don't. Don't do it. And you, $12 plus popcorn. You made kind of this, like you're doing now,
《绿灯侠》，你的反应是，祝你好运。我想我当时还警告过你。我说，别去。别去。留着电影票吧，别去了。别去。而你，花12美元还买了爆米花。你做出了一种，就像你现在正在做的这种，
a public admission that it didn't kind of maybe work out the way you had hoped, right? There's even that hilarious bit at the end of Deadpool. We have that script, it's so funny. So forget about like Hollywood for a second and share with us like how someone might be in a similar position somewhere in life professionally, that was a part of something that didn't meet expectations
公开承认这部电影并没有像你原本希望的那样发展，对吧？《死侍》结尾甚至还有那个超级搞笑的彩蛋。我们有那个剧本，太搞笑了。所以先暂时忘掉好莱坞这回事，跟我们分享一下，当某人在生活中或职业生涯中的某个阶段，身处类似的位置，却发现结果不如预期，或者不符合他们的愿望时，
or how they wanted. And so what was the drive or the path to say, okay, this didn't work, but we're going to go bigger and make the best thing more successfully. Was it something inside of you that said, I know I can make Deadpool this role successful? I'm going to try it again,
他们内心的驱动力是什么，或者会采取怎样的路径去说：好吧，这没成功，但我们要把格局放大，做得更大，更成功地创造出最好的作品？是不是你内心有什么声音在说：我知道我能让《死侍》这个角色大获成功？我要再试一次，
because a lot of people would have given up after something like that. Well, you know, that's an- Sorry, Ryan, just not to cut you up. And Sean's saying that Green Lantern was so bad you should have quit. Go ahead. Go ahead.
因为经历过那种打击后，很多人都会选择放弃。嗯，你知道，这是一—抱歉，瑞安，不是故意打断你。肖恩说《绿灯侠》烂到你应该直接退圈。你接着说。你接着说。
Thank you for reading between the lines. My entire inner monologue is a gigantic comedic nod right now. You know, I think like I'm failing at starring in a gigantic comic book movie in the grand scheme of things is an extraordinarily uptown problem. So I think kind of reframing it a little bit like that, but then also-
谢谢你听懂了弦外之音。此刻我内心的独白完全就是一个巨大的喜剧式白眼。你知道，我觉得吧，主演一部超级烂的漫画改编电影在人生的大局中其实是一个极其“上流阶层”的烦恼。所以我觉得稍微用这种方式重新构架一下，不过同时——
But it's your life. Well, it's okay, it's your life. It is, you know, everything's a little bit bigger when it's your life. And at the time it really hurt because I realized that it was, I let a lot of people down. It sort of felt like, you know,
但这是你的人生啊。好吧，没关系，这是你的人生。确实，你知道，当事情发生在你身上时，一切都会被放大。而且当时真的很受伤，因为我意识到，我让很多人失望了。那种感觉就像是，你知道的，
when it's you and the public discourse about that, everything feels much bigger than it actually is, you know? So I felt a little bit like I'd let people down. I, you know, people really loved that character. And I didn't love that feeling, you know? But I think what changed everything was finding a way to have gentle authorship in the work that I do as opposed to that unilateral power,
当只有你一个人面对公众对这件事的议论时，一切感觉都比实际情况要宏大得多，你知道吗？所以我当时觉得有点对不起大家。我知道，大家真的很喜欢那个角色。我真的很不喜欢那种感觉，你知道吗？但我觉得改变一切的关键在于，在我的工作中找到一种温和的掌控感，而不是那种单方面的强权，
like walking into a room and saying, I'm the boss. This is how it's gonna be my way of the highway. It's really finding a way to truly collaborate with people. And the best leaders I know, and this applies to all forms of business and the arts, but the best leaders I know are the ones that are very, very comfortable saying,
比如走进房间大喊：“我是老大。事情就得按我的规矩办，不服别干。”而是真正找到一种与他人真诚合作的方式。我认识的最优秀的领导者——这适用于各行各业以及艺术领域——他们都有一个共同点，那就是他们非常、非常坦然地说出：
I don't know. So how can we get to a place where we know, can someone in this room show me or teach me? And those are great leaders. So I think harnessing some of those kinds of things, you know, basically grinding up 45 self-help books and snorting it like the biggest line of coke you've ever seen, also kind of help you shape
“我不知道。”那么我们怎样才能达成共识呢？房间里有人能展示给我看或教教我吗？这些才是伟大的领导者。所以我想，利用这些经验，你知道，基本上就是把45本自助书磨碎，然后像吸有生以来最大的一道可卡因一样把它吸进去，也能帮你塑造
some of these points of view. Right. But that was the thing that I think kind of changed my life. And then it allowed me to sort of take that energy around that particular movie and use it a little bit like Judo uses energy against it and kind of ramp. I mean, one of the great prides of my life
其中的一些观点。对。但这正是改变我人生的那件事。然后它让我得以转化围绕那部特定电影的能量，有点像柔道那样借力打力，然后……我的意思是，我一生中最引以为傲的事情之一
was writing the tag on Deadpool 2 where Deadpool kills Ryan Reynolds while he's reading the script for Green Lantern. And I just like- That is so funny. It was like a lot of- So clever. That kind of stuff is so fun to me, you know,
就是写了《死侍2》的彩蛋：死侍在瑞安·雷诺兹阅读《绿灯侠》剧本时杀死了他。我当时就——太搞笑了。这真的很像——太聪明了。这种梗对我来说太有趣了，你知道吗，
to be able to do that. And also I think, well, part of it, what you're talking about is you don't, and you seemingly never have taken yourself too seriously. And I think that that's really important. It's a, and people see it as armor. It's not really, it's actually kind of a great way to go through life.
能做到这一点。而且我觉得，部分原因在于你所说的，你不会——而且你似乎从来没有——把你自己看得太重。我认为这真的很重要。人们把它看作是盔甲。其实并不是，这实际上是一种很好的人生哲学。
If you don't take yourself too seriously, then the slings and arrows don't hurt as much. No, not at all. And so you, yeah, and you have a healthy, and I think there's a very, you also have a very kind of Canadian outlook on life in certain ways. Certainly I identify with that, which is like,
如果你不把自己看得太重，那么那些明枪暗箭就不会那么伤人了。不，一点也不。所以你，对，而且你有一种健康的，我觉得在某种程度上也非常具有加拿大人特质的人生观。我当然很有同感，那就是：
hey man, it's like you said, like it's an uptown problem. It's all kind of a gas. I mean, the fact that we're fucking doing it is hilarious. You're making a living at it. I mean, my father, if he were alive today, you know, he'd probably find some new way to die. But if he were alive today, he would, you know, dark, he would, you know, he'd be like, holy shit.
嘿，老兄，就像你说的，这只是个上流社会的烦恼。一切都不过是个笑话。我的意思是，我们他妈的正在做这件事，这本身就很搞笑。你靠这个谋生。我的意思是，我父亲如果今天还活着，你知道，他可能会找到某种死的新方式。但如果他今天还活着，你知道，他会，语气阴暗地说，你知道，他会说：“卧槽。”
You're living like the life at Riley here. Like, come on. Yeah. Sean, what would your dad say? My dad would say, what's your name? Yeah. That's what my dad would say. Over the sound of the departing car engine.
你在这里过着神仙般的日子。拜托。对。肖恩，你爸爸会说什么？我爸爸会说：“你叫什么名字？”对。我爸会这么说。伴随着逐渐远去的汽车引擎声。
Oh no. Sean's dad left when he was five. Sean's dad left when he was five. And so it's a big, it's a recurring joke on the show. My dad canceled Christmas one year. I'm not kidding. He said Christmas is canceled. And it is just like, to this day,
哦，不。肖恩五岁时他爸爸就抛弃他了。肖恩五岁时他爸爸就抛弃他了。所以这是一个很大、在节目中经常出现的笑话。我爸有一年取消了圣诞节。我没开玩笑。他说圣诞节取消了。直到今天，
it's still makes my brother and I fall over laughing. What year did Blake and her little angel wings float down into your life? During what projects and how did that? Hey man, don't say it so fucking creepily in that way. She's such an angel. Don't describe his wife as an angel floating down here. Will, straight from heaven.
这依然让我和我哥笑得前仰后合。布莱克和她的小天使翅膀是什么时候飞进你生命里的？是在哪个项目期间，又是怎么……嘿，老兄，别用那种真他妈让人毛骨悚然的语气说话。她简直就是个天使。别把他的老婆形容成一只飞到这儿来的天使。好吧，直接从天堂来的。
Straight from heaven. Just say, when did you meet Blake, like a normal fucking person? But I want to know what the little, what the wings flapping did for his life and his career, and then children, did it change anything, or did it just complicate stuff and affect your overhead? No, no, no.
直接从天堂来的。你就直接说，你是什么时候遇到布莱克的，像个正常人一样，行吗？但我很想知道那些扑腾的翅膀对他的生活和事业有什么影响，还有孩子，这改变了什么，还是说只是让事情变得更复杂并增加了你的日常开销？不，不，不。
This is the only fucking guy on earth who would look at a family as overhead. I know, it's so true. Yes. This is the line item for daughter, I'm just gonna fuck her. No, I met Blake on the darkest crease in the anus of the universe called Green Lantern, and we were friends and buddies,
这绝对是地球上唯一一个会把家庭视作“日常开销”的混蛋。我知道，太真实了。对。这是女儿这一项的开支，我只是随便说说。不，我是在宇宙肛门最黑暗的褶皱里——也就是《绿灯侠》剧组——遇到布莱克的，我们当时是朋友和哥们儿，
and then about a year and a half later, we actually went on a double date, but we were dating separate people. Wow. Really? She was doubling with someone else. Oh, God. She went on a date with someone else,
然后大约一年半后，我们其实去了一次双人约会，但我们当时约会的是不同的人。哇。真的吗？她当时和别人一起约会。哦，天哪。她跟别人去约会了，
and I was on a date with someone else, and we hung out and kind of, we always kind of kept in touch, but sort of casually, and then next thing you know, she was going to Boston, I was going to Boston, so I was like, well, I'll ride with you. We got on the train and rode together,
而我也在跟别人约会，我们一起玩得很开心，而且我们一直保持着联系，只是那种随意的联系，然后接下来的事你们知道了，她要去波士顿，我也要去波士顿，所以我就想，好吧，那我跟你一起走吧。我们上了火车，一路同行，
and then, you know, I was just begging her to sleep with me. Who made the first move, was it you? Yes. Yeah, yeah. And how did that, so let's get into that. What does a first move look like? I mean, is it like, and I've done this move actually in a movie theater where you put girls sitting next
然后，你知道的，我一直在死皮赖脸地求她跟我睡。谁先迈出第一步的，是你吗？对。对，对。那事情是怎样的，我们来聊聊这个。第一步是怎么样的？我的意思是，是不是像——其实我在电影院里用过这招，你让女孩坐在你
to you, you stretch out both arms, one over the back of her chair, and one over the back of the empty chair next to you, so it looks like you just relaxed, and then about five minutes later, you take the other arm down, you scratch your leg, and you leave the one behind her up. Now I got my arm around her.
旁边，你伸出两条胳膊，一只搭在她椅子的靠背上，另一只搭在你旁边空椅子的靠背上，这样看起来你只是很放松，然后大约五分钟后，你把另一只胳膊拿下来，挠挠腿，把留在她身后的那只胳膊继续放着。现在我的胳膊就搂着她了。
So that was one of my first moves. Wow. This is like ninth grade stuff. You're like the fucking font. Yeah, man, so it was yours as good as that, or was it? No, mine was much more elaborate. I mean, I would use a little bit of tear stick, so I'd get the tears kind of rolled and coming out.
所以这是我的绝招之一。哇。这简直是初中生水平的把戏。你简直就是个情圣。对啊，老兄，那你的招数有这么好吗，还是说？不，我的要复杂得多。我的意思是，我会用一点眼泪膏，所以我会让眼泪涌出来并流下来。
You can gently sort of put it underneath your eyelids, and then I would tell a little sob story about my life, and how my hardship, my Eastern block hardship upbringing. How about how important your virginity is to you? Yeah. Did you use it? Oh my God, of course. Like as soon as I was in love,
你可以轻轻地把它涂在眼睑下面，然后我会讲一个关于我生活的小苦情故事，讲我的艰难困苦，我那东欧背景的艰难成长史。还有你的童贞对你有多重要？对。你用过这招吗？哦，天哪，当然用过。只要我坠入爱河，
I was like, listen, we're not sitting together, all right? It's not happening. So you guys are friends, so how long after you started dating, so you're friends, then you start dating, how long were you guys like, this is the real deal? Pretty quick. Honestly, it was kind of one of those silly sort of,
我就会说：听着，我们不能坐在一起，好吗？没门儿。所以你们是朋友，那么在你们开始约售后多久——你们先是朋友，然后开始约会——你们相处了多久之后才觉得：这就是真爱了？挺快的。说实话，这有点像那种傻乎乎的，
like out of a very, I was like a week later, I was like, we should buy a house together. Wow. I know, and we did. Because it was getting too expensive to drive back and forth, so it was really about the bottom line, the overhead, it would just be more efficient to own a house together.
就像非常……大约一周后，我就说：我们应该一起买栋房子。哇。我知道，我们真的买了。因为来回奔波的油费太贵了，所以这其实是出于成本和日常开销的考虑，一起买栋房子会更有效率。
Yeah, we just, again, the overhead, right? Same thing with me. How long have you guys been together? And then, you know. How long have you guys been together? We've been together almost 10 years. Nice. Yeah, that's like 45 years in Hollywood terms.
对，我们只是，还是那句话，日常开销，对吧？我和我老婆也一样。你们俩在一起多久了？然后，你知道的。你们在一起多久了？我们在一起快十年了。不错。对，在好莱坞算得上是45年了。
Yeah, oh, sure is. Two kids, yes? Three. Three daughters. Wow. Yes. Thanks, Bateman. I know.
对，哦，确实是。有两个孩子，对吧？三个。三个女儿。哇。是的。谢谢你，贝特曼。我知道。
Listen, you know. You couldn't throw a little Google search in there while we were talking here. No, we're to alienate Ryan. Ryan, I want to ask you to do something about it because I follow you on Instagram and you posted something that was pretty awesome that I can relate to, which is anxiety.
听着，你知道的。我们在聊天的时候，你连个谷歌搜索都懒得查一下吗。不，我们这是在疏远瑞安。瑞安，我想让你做点什么，因为我在Instagram上关注了你，你发过一些非常棒的内容，我对此深有同感，那就是关于焦虑。
It's about anxiety. Yes. And you're open about the anxiety you have and I'm pretty much open about the one I have. And this is your quote, which I love. I have anxiety. Yes, you do. It says, to all those like me who over schedule,
是关于焦虑的。是的。你对自己的焦虑直言不讳，而我对我的焦虑也基本直言不讳。这是你的原话，我超爱：“我有焦虑。”是的，你确实有。上面写着：“致所有像我一样过度规划、
over think, over work, over worry and over everything, please know you're not alone. I love that. Why? And see, that's what I was trying to get to before was you do all of those things because and is that you attribute all of those things, not attribute, but you associate all of those things
过度思考、过度工作、过度担忧以及过度操心一切的人，请知道你们并不孤单。”我太喜欢这句话了。为什么？看吧，这正是我之前想说的，你做所有这些事情是因为——你把所有这些事情都归因于——不是归因，而是你把所有这些事情都
with having anxiety. And if you associate anxiety with success, isn't it scary to get rid of it? Well, that's the dangerous tightrope walk. I think a lot of people are on, right? It's, I see anxiety as a sort of an engine in a way, sometimes for creativity, but it also has, it's like, it's got its own sort of cloud
与焦虑联系在一起。如果你把焦虑和成功联系在一起，摆脱它难道不是很可怕吗？嗯，那是许多人都在走的危险钢丝，对吧？我认为焦虑有时可以作为创造力的某种引擎，但它也有着它自己的一团
and shroud of darkness. So I'm grateful for my anxiety, which has allowed me to kind of transmute it a little bit and make it useful, which I think is always great. But then there's a lot of insomnia associated. There's a lot of sleepless nights where you're laying awake, over analyzing everything. And it's very hard to turn one's brain off.
阴云和黑暗面。所以我很感激我的焦虑，它让我能够稍微转化它并让它发挥作用，我觉得这总是很好的。但随之而来的也有很多失眠。有很多不眠之夜，你醒着躺在那里，对一切过度分析。要让自己的大脑停下来是非常困难的。
Right. So that's where you start to rely on other, meditation and all kinds of other things, just to kind of get yourself back to a centered place. But yeah, anxiety is something that like, it's been with me my whole life. It's started as a kid, being in a house that wasn't, my household that I grew up in wasn't overly awful,
对。所以这就是你开始依赖其他东西的时候，冥想以及各种其他方法，只是为了让自己回到一个中心点。但对，焦虑这种东西，它伴随了我一生。它从小时候就开始了，生活在一个并不——我成长的那种家庭并不算特别糟糕，
I wouldn't say in the grand scheme of things, certainly compared to some people, but my dad was never an easy person to be around. He was like a skin covered landmine. Like you just never knew when you're gonna step on the wrong spot and he was just gonna explode. So it creates a situation where as a kid, you start to really try to predict the future.
比起某些人来，在大局上看我不会说有多糟，但我爸绝对不是个好相处的人。他就像一个披着人皮的地雷。你永远不知道什么时候会踩错地方，然后他就彻底炸了。所以这就造成了一种情况：作为小孩子，你开始拼命去预测未来。
And I think predicting the future is a big brick in the wall of anxiety, which is we cannot predict the future. So you're constantly living in this thing that may or may not happen, this place or space that may or may not happen. So you know, but then in this business, we all kind of tend to do that, right?
我认为预测未来是焦虑之墙上的一块大砖头，那就是：我们无法预测未来。所以你总是生活在可能会发生也可能不会发生的事情中，生活在可能会发生也可能不会发生的地方或空间里。所以你知道，但在这一行里，我们大家往往都会这样，对吧？
We project into the future. What's it like to be this person? What's it like to comedies a little bit like that? There's, it's a music and it's, you're thinking, how do I come 90 degrees to expectation in this moment? And that's, it's all kind of born of that same thing, those wheels that just sort of don't shut off.
我们会投射到未来。成为这个人是什么感觉？喜剧有点像那样。这是一种音乐，你在想：此刻我该如何做出完全出乎意料的反应？这都是由同样的东西催生的，那些永远不会停转的齿轮。
I think that anxiety when you can't turn it off, when you can't turn your brain off, that is one form. And I know that Sean struggles with his anxiety because he can't turn his brain on. And that's often, yeah. Well, my cord, my cord won't reach far enough to the outlet. It's just, I walk, I walk a certain,
我认为当你的焦虑无法关闭，当你无法让大脑停转时，这是一种形式。我知道肖恩一直在跟他的焦虑作斗争，因为他的大脑根本无法开启。这通常是，对。嗯，我的电源线长度根本够不到插座。我只要走，只要我走，
if I walk anywhere further than 10 feet, the plug comes out of the wall. Does this little this thing ever go on? Will there ever be a thought? Listen, what's going on with you and Hugh Jackman are obviously in this huge beef. And you obviously, you guys have had some words. Wait, fill me in.
如果我走到距离超过10英尺的地方，插头就会从墙上脱落。这小东西到底有没有开过机？脑子里有过哪怕一个想法吗？听着，你和休·杰克曼之间到底怎么回事，显然你们俩在闹极大的矛盾。而且你们俩显然说过一些狠话。等等，跟我讲讲。
What happened? Well, I guess he and Hugh- That guy's going to be tap dancing in hell. Yeah. I've seen a few posts and it gets pretty, it gets pretty real. What's going on here? Who pissed somebody off?
发生什么了？好吧，我猜他和休——那家伙在地狱里也会跳踢踏舞。我看到过一些帖子，而且感觉越来越真了。这到底是怎么回事？谁惹谁生气了？
You know, Hugh Jackman is, I really shouldn't say this, but he is, he really is- This is a family podcast, by the way, okay? I know. He makes like kindness look like murder. I mean, he's really is just the nicest guy you'd ever meet. And that's, trust me, not sometimes.
你知道，休·杰克曼是个——我真的不该这么说，但他真的是——顺便说一句，这是个家庭播客，好吗？我知道。他把“善良”搞得像谋杀一样。我的意思是，他真的是你能见过的最nice的人。相信我，不是有时。
No, no, there's no but, unfortunately. He's, he really is the real deal. You're questioning the sincerity of his kindness. No? No, it's just, it's infuriating because I want to- Because it's so real. I got it. I want to possess the sense of well-being that Hugh Jackman possesses.
不，不，没有“但是”，不幸的是。他，他真的是名不虚传。你在质疑他善良的真诚度吗？不？不，只是这太让人气愤了，因为我想——因为它是如此真实。我懂了。我想拥有休·杰克曼所拥有的那种内心安宁感。
And it turns into anger for you. I want to understand that to some degree. So we sometimes hate and lash out at the things that we cannot understand. Sure. So I tend to hate and lash out at Hugh. And he does, he reciprocates of course, because he's nothing if not a sportsman.
然后这就变成了你的愤怒。我想在某种程度上理解这一点。所以我们有时会憎恨并抨击那些我们无法理解的事物。当然。所以我往往会憎恨并抨击休。当然，他也会回击，因为他是个极具体育精神的人。
And that's kind of it. But in reality though, he is like my kind of life Sherpa. Sherpa is one of the best guys I know. I'm doing a film right now where I'm, it's a musical where I have to sing and dance, which is for me is like my actual version of hell. What is it? And a challenge.
事情就是这样。但现实中，他其实就像是我的人生向导。向导是我认识的最好的人之一。我现在正在拍一部电影，是一部音乐剧，我必须在里面唱歌跳舞，对我来说这简直就是我现实中的地狱版本。是什么？也是一个挑战。
Yeah, why would you do that? Are you supposed to be a bad singer and dancer? No, I'm supposed to be pretty, I'm doing it with our friend of the court, Will Ferrell. We're in song and dance camp right now for the next month and a half. God, he's the best, isn't he? The best.
对，你为什么要接这出戏？你是扮演一个唱歌跳舞都很烂的人吗？不，我应该表现得挺好的，我是和我们的老朋友威尔·费瑞尔一起拍的。接下来的一个半月里，我们都在进行歌舞集训。天哪，他最棒了，不是吗？最棒的。
Oh, great. Isn't he the best? I'm like that Chris Farley sketch with them. I was like, remember when you, remember when you were Neil Diamond in Songwriters and Storytelling? I know. Wait, you guys are doing a movie together?
哦，太棒了。他难道不是最棒的吗？我当时就像克里斯·法利（Chris Farley）那个模仿他们的素描小品。我就像，还记得你，还记得你在《词曲作者与故事讲述》里扮演尼尔·戴蒙德（Neil Diamond）的时候吗？我知道。等等，你们俩一起拍电影？
I'm gonna be first in line for that. What is it called? When's it coming out? It's called Spirited and it's a musical for Apple. And it's just been a real journey. When Jason says he's first in line, he means first in line calling his publicist to get tickets for him and the kids to go to the premiere.
我绝对要排在队伍的最前面去看。叫什么名字？什么时候上映？叫《 Spirited : 充满活力的圣诞节》（Spirited），是为苹果公司拍的一部音乐剧。这真是一段奇妙的旅程。当杰森说他是排在第一位的时候，他的意思是第一个打电话给公关，为他和孩子们搞到首映礼门票的人。
No, no, no, no. Christmas is our 2022. Is there a Christmas theme to it? Yeah. It's a real musical. Wow. Like who wrote the music? Here we go.
不，不，不，不。2022年圣诞档。这里面有圣诞主题吗？对。是一部真正的音乐剧。哇。音乐是谁写的？来喽。
Passick and Paul. Justin Paul and Benji Passick. Oh, they're fantastic. Outlaw, La Land and Greatest Showman, Evan Hansen. And they're just amazing, amazing, best songwriters ever. Yeah, that's great. Yeah, they wrote the songs for real singers.
帕塞克和保罗。贾斯汀·保罗和本杰·帕塞克。哦，他们太棒了。《爱乐之城》和《马戏之王》、《致埃文·汉森》的词曲。他们简直太惊艳了，是有史以来最棒的词曲作者。对，太棒了。对，他们是为真正的歌手写歌的。
That's the problem. Oh, okay. But you sing. So how do you think it's going? You're camp, do you wanna fire yourself yet or not? Oh, I would definitely, but I would fire myself from almost anything, particularly fatherhood.
这就是问题所在。哦，好吧。但你要唱歌。所以你觉得进展如何？你在集训营里，你想好什么时候把自己开除掉了吗？哦，我当然想过，但我从几乎任何事上都能把自己开除，尤其是当父亲。
Not true. So, Ryan, what would our listener be surprised to learn that you do when you are not being philanthropic or a key member of the entertainment industry? What do you do to, like, McElhaney, me and Will, we play a lot of golf. Do you do any of the golfing or... Oh, God.
才没有。所以，瑞安，当你不做慈善事业或不是娱乐界的核心成员时，我们的听众如果知道你会做些什么，会感到惊讶？你平时会做些什么来——就像麦克尔尼、我和威尔，我们经常打高尔夫球。你会打高尔夫球吗，还是说……哦，天哪。
What do you do to be an idiot? I envy golf, because it sounds so meditative, right? Like, you go out and you just walk. Yeah, you walk. You know, I will tip it, like, when I'm in New York, when I'm at home, you know, I'll go, like, I'll do like crazy walks. Like, I'll go for four hours, if I can.
你平时做什么来当个傻子？我很羡慕高尔夫，因为听起来太具有冥想性了，对吧？比如你出去走走就行。对，散步。你知道，如果我在纽约，在家里的话，我会，你知道，我会去进行疯狂的散步。如果可以的话，我会走上四个小时。
Have you ever walked all the way around the island of Manhattan? No, never that long. I'll go, like, from downtown to, like, the tip of Central Park, which is, takes, like, three hours. Wait, are you in New York now? Yeah. Oh, I didn't know you lived there. They're East Coasters.
你有没有环绕曼哈顿岛走过一整圈？没有，从来没有走那么久。我一般会从市中心走到中央公园的顶端，这大概需要三个小时。等等，你现在在纽约吗？对。哦，我不知道你住在那里。他们是东海岸人。
I love that you guys are East Coasters. I am in Paul Bunyan's asshole right now. I know where you are. This is where I live. Oh, wait, have I seen this house? No, you moved, I think, in the house I saw, right? I don't think you've been here, no. No, they had to change numbers and addresses.
我喜欢你们都是东海岸人。我现在在保罗·班扬（Paul Bunyan）的屁眼里。我知道你在哪。这就是我住的地方。哦，等等，我见过这栋房子吗？没有，你搬家了，我想是在我看到的那栋房子之后，对吧？我觉得你没来过这里，没有。没有，他们不得不更换号码和地址。
Sorry, Jason. Well, what? You don't even know how many kids he has. Why do you think he'd have you at the house? Oh, and who's this little one? Yeah. Who is this little? No, did you hear on a play day?
抱歉，杰森。什么？你甚至不知道他有几个孩子。你为什么觉得他会请你去做客？哦，那这个小不点是谁呀？对。这个小不点是谁？不，你在玩耍日的时候听说过吗？
Was the third for, like, just, like, emergency harvestable organs, or did you want the third? Jason turns to Blake and goes, um, Angel, Angel Wings, who is this little one? And she's like, don't call me fucking Angel Wings. Did this third one give you a more favorable tax bracket? Is that why you? Is that Amanda's name?
老三生下来是为了当紧急可移植器官储备库的，还是你本来就想要老三？杰森转头对布莱克说：“嗯，天使，天使翅膀，这个小不点是谁？”然后她说：“别他妈叫我天使翅膀。”这个老三给你带来了更划算的税率吗？这就是你……是阿曼达的名字吗？
Do you guys, do you guys have, like, a, like a, is she, is she boo? We, um, I, I don't, I don't think I've called her the same thing twice in 20 years. I, I, and my kids the same thing. It drives whatever it is. It works though. I guess.
你们俩，你们俩平时会，比如，她是不是，她是不是你的宝贝？我们，嗯，我，我，我觉得我20年来没有用同一个词叫过她两次。我对我的孩子也是这样。这让人抓狂。不过管用就行。我猜是的。
You know, it's so funny. I, for it with Scotty, my husband Scotty, I think it's so awkward on sitcoms when characters call the other character by name over and over and over again. So I, because nobody does that in life. So I do it with Scotty. I always say, Scotty, do you want to grab something to eat tonight, Scotty?
你知道，太好笑了。我和我的丈夫斯科蒂在一起时，我觉得情景喜剧里的角色一遍又一遍地直呼对方的名字，真的超级尴尬。因为现实生活中根本没有人会那样做。所以我对斯科蒂也是这样。我总是说：“斯科蒂，今晚你想出去吃点东西吗，斯科蒂？”
Scotty, I don't know because it's so unnatural. I think I always bust my balls about this cause I can never just say, um, I, I did a movie this last year with Dwayne Johnson and I, but I always say Dwayne the Rock Johnson. Like I go through the full, I mean, literally like the sun rises and sets before I can make it to the end of his full name. You know, Dwayne the Rock Johnson, I'm doing a scene today
“斯科蒂，我不知道……”因为这太不自然了。我想我总是因为这个被大家取笑，因为我永远无法只说……我去年跟道恩·强森拍了一部电影，但我总是说“巨石道恩·强森”。我总是把全称念完，我的意思是，字面意思上，太阳从东边升起又落下，我还没念完他的全名呢。你知道的，“巨石道恩·强森”，我今天要跟巨石道恩·强森拍一场戏。
with Dwayne the Rock Johnson. She's like, I understand. You could go with DJ D, the rock, the big guy, Dwayne, but people in Boston do that. They don't notice they go, matter of fact, Will, uh, we were over there at, uh, we're out in Dedham, Will, and, uh, Will, we see the other guy that will, and you're like, stop using my name so much.
她说：“我懂了。你可以叫他DJ、D、巨石、大块头、道恩。”但波士顿人就是这样。他们不会……他们会说：“事实上，威尔，我们当时在那儿，我们在戴德姆，威尔，然后，威尔，我们看到了另一个人，威尔……”然后你就说：“别老用我的名字行吗？”
You know what I'm saying? Let's go through things that we hate that people say, like little pet peeves. Are we ready? Cause I got another one loaded up. Okay. I can't imagine you have one. Watching fucking hockey these days.
你知道我在说什么吗？我们来盘点一下那些我们讨厌别人说的话，比如一些小口头禅。准备好了吗？因为我这儿还有一个压箱底的。好吧。我简直无法想象你会有这种烦恼。这些天看他妈的冰球。
Okay. And I'm so, and not just hockey, but all sports and answers, stop saying without a doubt or without question. They constantly, constantly going, well, without question, they're, you know, the Leafs are, uh, they're, they're not, you know, fighting through the neutral zone and without question, without question. Yeah.
好吧。不仅是冰球，还有所有的体育运动和解说，别再说什么“毫无疑问”或“毫无悬念”了。他们一直在说，一直在说：“嗯，毫无疑问，他们，你知道的，枫叶队，呃，他们在，他们没有，你知道的，在通过中立区时拼搏，毫无疑问，毫无疑问。”对。
I don't know. I think it's very common people will start to say something and they'll just throw in the, the conformational right in the middle of the thing. Um, so, you know, when you're walking down the street, right? You're, uh, you're thinking about, uh, you know, how nice it is, right? And, and the right is getting very overused nowadays.
我不知道。我觉得很常见的一种情况是，人们开始说一句话时，会在正中间硬生生地塞进一个表示确认的词。所以，你知道，当你走在街上，对吧？你在，呃，你在想，呃，这有多好，对吧？现在“对吧”这个词被严重滥用了。
The one that, the one that just cripples me though is, is, is guy. Hey, guy. Hey, guy. Can I have a. But we did that for years. Jason and I did that. And we used to, it's in a few episodes of arrested development where we'll turn to each other and go, yeah, hey, guy, I've
不过，那个让我抓狂的词是“老兄”。嘿，老兄。嘿，老兄。我能要一个……但我们以前用过好多年。我和杰森用过。在几集《发展受阻》里，我们会转过头对彼此说：“对啊，嘿，老兄，我……”
heard you just say that, Jason in a, in a, in a, in a, in a comedy context, because it's, I love it because it's like, you may as well just say like, Hey, peanuts hooked up to a life support system. What, uh, you know, it's just so generic. Did you ever see what Jason, what's that movie you did in the desert with Peter Berg and, uh, everybody? Oh, uh, kingdom.
我听过你这么说，杰森，是在一个喜剧语境里，因为我超爱这个，因为这就好比你在说：“嘿，连着生命维持系统的花生豆。”什么，你知道的，这太大众化了。你有没有看过杰森……你跟彼得·伯格和大家在沙漠里拍的那部电影叫什么来着？哦，呃，《反恐王国》。
Kingdom. Jason has a, as a role in kingdom and one of my favorite line readings of all time, they're speeding through the desert. And I remember seeing this in the theater with Krasinski and we're, you're speeding through the desert and the guy's going way too fast. And Jason goes, Hey driver, are you late for something? My character has anxiety.
《王国》。杰森在《王国》里有个角色，那是我有生以来最喜欢的台词念法之一。他们在沙漠里超速飙车。我记得我和卡拉辛斯基在电影院里看这个，你们在沙漠里超速飙车，那家伙开得太快了。杰森就说：“嘿，司机，你赶着去投胎吗？”我的角色有焦虑症。
He does. He doesn't like the speeding. It's his throwaways though that like, I, the, the, what's the, what's the one that kills? There's one that just fucking kills me. It'll come to me in a second. I did change guy to gang recently, just like saying, even if it's a single person, we're going to, guns hot is the one I
他确实有。他不喜欢超速。不过是他那些随口而出的废话——那个，那个让人抓狂的词是什么？有一个简直他妈的笑死我了。我一会儿就能想起来。我最近把“老兄”换成了“各位”，就像是说，即使面对单个人也是如此……我们在《互换身体》里一直用“枪栓上膛”这个梗，当时莱斯莉·曼恩翻了个身，在床上放了个小屁，而杰森——也就是现在的我，我的精神化身——却说：“嘿，你敢来挑衅我？枪栓上膛。”我们都这么说，肖恩·利维也这么说。我们所有人都这么说，字面意思上随时随地都在说。
still use from the change up when you, when Leslie man rolls over and it passes a little gas in the bed and Jason, who's now me, my psyche, but he goes, Hey, you're going to, you're going to come at me. Guns hot. We all said, Sean Levy says it. We all said all that. I mean, literally all the time.
我得再去看一遍那部电影。我真的很喜欢。我觉得自从我们在拉肯亚达（La Cañada）之类的地方看过之后，就再也没看过它了。我们看了你参演的那部电影。好吧，对。你为了一部作品辛辛苦苦几个月，结果最后只看了一遍。
I'm going to see that movie again. I really liked that. I feel like I've not seen it since we saw it in like, in La Kenyatta or something. We saw the movie you were in. Well, yeah. I only saw it the once you work on something for months and then you just see it one time.
你讨厌别人说什么？你的口头禅是什么，肖恩？“回头再讨论”。我讨厌“回头再讨论”。回头再讨论。哦，“回头再讨论”。回头再讨论。嘿，让我们讨论一下。
What do you hate that people say? What's yours, Sean? Circle back. I hate circle back. Circle back. Oh, circle back. Circle back. Hey, let us discuss.
然后我们要“回头再讨论”或“保持联系”或者“根据我之前的电子邮件”。你为什么不直接说：“我他妈没回复你”呢？你为什么不针对我的短信也这么说：“根据我之前的短信，在期待我们的对话的同时，请查阅附件中的……”你知道的，口述但未阅读。这有点像业内黑话。你是故意不回复贝特曼的，因为你当时想：
And we're going to circle back or touch base or per my previous email. Why don't you just say, I didn't fucking get back to you. Why don't you do that with me on your text per my previous text in anticipation of our conversation? Please see the included, you know, dictated, but not read. That's a little inside baseball. Did you purposely not respond to Bateman because you're just
管他呢，他不懂。我们回到正题上来。现在，我要说的是：这是对这一系列事件的一种非常宽容的解释。我认为是的。我们姑且相信苹果公司的说法吧。
like, fuck it. He doesn't know. Let's get back to this. Now, here's what I'm going to say. This is a very generous interpretation of the series of events. I think it is. Let's believe it on Apple.
苹果公司的短信功能有个毛病。你无法将一条短信标记为未读，因为如果你读了一条短信，然后心里想：“哦，天哪，我真的很想给这个人一个好的回复，这值得我花更多的时间去关注，但我现在没时间这么做，我稍后再弄。”结果没有任何提醒告诉你稍后还有这条短信，于是你
Apple has a problem with texting. You cannot mark a text as unread because if you read a text and they go, oh, boy, I really want to give a good response to this person. It deserves my attention a longer, but I don't have the time to do that right now. I'll do it later. There's no reminder that that text came in later and you could
可能会几个月都不回复，然后对于发信人来说，这显得，嗯，挺伤人的，你知道吧。如果苹果能允许我们这样做，那就太贴心了。这只是一个简单的更新。现在我要对你绝对坦诚。我收到你的短信了。哦，天哪。我想上这个节目的。
go months without responding to it and then seem, well, hurtful, I guess, you know, to the person who sent it to you. It would be a kind thing of Apple to do is to allow us to do that. It's a simple update. I'm going to be completely honest with you right now. I got your text. Oh, boy. I wanted to be on the show.
不过还有一件事。这要追溯到我昨天发的那条小帖子。这要追溯到我们刚才谈论的事情，那就是当遇到这种事情时，我真的会像缩头乌龟一样畏缩不前，但当我身处那些我极为尊敬和崇拜的人当中时——这可不是我在这里对你拍马屁、瞎吹牛——我告诉你，我其实有这种感觉，所以我有点像，哦，天哪，
Here's the other thing though. This goes back to my little post yesterday. This goes back to the thing that we were talking about is I get really like, I turtle a little bit when it's stuff like that, but I'm getting around people that I greatly respect and admire, and this isn't me just pumping a bunch of hyperbole into your balloon knob. I'm telling you, I actually feel, so I get a little like, oh, God,
那是什么？就像，我需要了解，我需要听听那个播客。然后我开始听，接着我就爱上了这个播客，而这让事情变得更糟了。就在上一次，你问的时候，你请过一个嘉宾，感觉有点“平平无奇”。当时我就想：哦，那我也能上。对。
what is that? Like, I need to understand, I need to hear that podcast. And then I started to, then I fell in love with the podcast and That made it worse. Just last time when you asked that you had someone on that was like, meh. And I was like, oh, then I can do this. Yeah.
现在我懂了。那是谁？是谁？是谁？绝对不是蒂娜·菲（Tina Fey），我可以告诉你。蒂娜·菲很棒。她很少出错。
Now I get it. Who was it? Who was it? Who was it? Who was not Tina Fey? I'll tell you that. Tina Fey is good. She doesn't miss a lot of things.
不，没有人平平无奇。只是当时时机不对而已。我也发现，在疫情期间——我意识到我并不是数以百万计的那些在疫情期间靠薪水过活、生活在极度恐慌中的普通人之一。我不是那些人中的一员。我很幸运。我很富有。
No, nobody was meh. It was just one of the things where I just wasn't the right time. I also found that the pandemic, and I realized that I'm not one of the millions and millions of people who are living at home paycheck to paycheck and living in an abject state of panic during a pandemic. I am one of the people who is not. I'm lucky. I'm fortunate.
我有能力不那样。但当时确实经历了一段艰难的时期，我的意思是，你知道的，当你得在家教孩子时，我相信很多人都能感同身受。他们表现得怎么样？他们过得怎么样？他们当时过得很艰难吗？对，一样。我当时到处寻找外部援助，丢三落四的，所以我一直在看书。
I'm able to not. But I was having a, that was a tough, I mean, you know, when you're homeschooling kids, I'm sure a lot of people can relate to this. How did they do? How did they do? Did they had a tough time? Yeah, same. I was like seeking out external help, left her and so I was reading books.
我当时试图找出某种方法来稳住这艘破船。所以布莱克在这方面比我强太多了，因为我也像个小孩子。但就个人而言，当你拥有一个富有创造力的头脑却经历了疫情时，你很难——而且你被困在家里的。我想这可能就是你刚才说的一部分原因吧，就是……对。你有没有开始做一些连自己都感到惊讶的事情？你开始画画了吗？
I was like trying to figure out some way to steer the shit. So Blake was so much better at it than I was because I'm also a child. But personally, when you have a creative mind and you go through a pandemic, it's hard to, and you're stuck at home. And I think maybe that's a little bit of what you're saying is like, Yeah. Did you start doing anything that you were surprised at? Did you start painting?
你开始削木头了吗？你开始玩黏土了吗？没有，我希望我会。我写了很多东西。我开始把冥想当作一种日常习惯。我知道这听起来有点深奥什么的，但它真的很有用。你有没有不小心睡着过好多次？因为我一冥想就会这样。
Did you start whittling? Did you start working with clay? No, I wish. I did a lot of writing. I started to like really make meditation a practice. I know it's like a little esoteric and everything, but it really did help. How many times did you accidentally fall asleep? Because that's what happens with me.
我现在已经放弃冥想了。杰森，如果我能拥有像你那样基础的内心安宁感，我做梦都会笑醒。我以前，我记得在拍《互换身体》的时候，我们工作时会互相问：“你睡足14个小时了吗？你睡饱了。”老头子确实挺会安稳睡觉的，就像一头贪婪的小猪，你什么都能捞到。对，不，我太想了，我他妈太想睡上一个不被打扰觉了。
I've given up on it now. Jason, if I had a baseline sense of well-being that you did, I would love it. I used to, I remember in the changeup, we'd worked kind of be like, did you get your 14 hours? You got it all. Granddad does know how to stay down pretty good. Like greedy little pig, you get it all. Yeah, no, I would love to, I would fucking love to just get some uninterrupted sleep.
听起来太棒了。不，冥想才不是那样的。我的冥想版本就像是以完美的直角坐着，然后无声地尖叫。对。太……张大嘴巴。
That sounds great. No, meditating is not. I mean, my version of meditating is like sitting at a perfect right angle and in a silent scream. Yeah. That's so... That's a... Mouth wide open.
下巴脱臼。嘴张得超级大。没有声音发出来。100%。对。对。对。瑞安，你觉得你的未来……
John hinged. The mouth is so wide open. No sound coming out. 100%. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Ryan, where do you see your...
你有三个孩子。你有这么多的事业。你在冥想。你在成为一个完整的人。显然你整天都在喝杜松子酒，因为你开了一家酒厂。当然。你娶了一个天使。所以你随时都处于半醉半醒的状态。
You've got three kids. You've got all this stuff. You're meditating. You're becoming a complete person. You're obviously drinking gin all day because you own a booze company. Sure. You're married to an angel. So you're constantly half in the bag.
你有了你可爱的小天使……耶稣基督。我愿意。他把你直接拽进这个污泥坑里了，不是吗？我知道。但你觉得未来的自己会怎样？我的意思是，似乎你现在所做的一切都在不断拓展。你现在正处于事业的巅峰期。
You've got your little pretty little angel. Jesus Christ. I will. He dragged you right into this smut puddle, didn't he? I know. But where do you see yourself? I mean, it seems like everything you're doing now just is opening up. You're just hitting your stride now.
你心里有没有一部分会想：“我已经做了很多，也取得了很大的成就，我只想放慢脚步，放松一下”，还是觉得：“不，咱们继续冲”？不断地这么想。我的意思是，我猜你们俩也是这么想的。你们总是会想：好吧，明年我得慢下来，你知道的。但我想我之所以能够以这种方式继续坚持下去，唯一的原因是我能陪伴我的孩子们和妻子，我的婚姻对我和我之间的友谊来说
Is there part of you that goes like, I've done a lot of accomplished a lot and I just kind of want to slow it down and just chill or do you feel like, no, just let's just keep rolling? Constantly. I mean, I would assume that you guys feel the same way. You're always thinking like, okay, next year I'll slow it down, you know, but the only reason I think I'm able to continue doing this at this way, I think is that I'm present with my kids and my wife and my marriage is incredibly important to me and that friendship
都是极其重要的。我，你知道的，我能够挺过来，你知道的，不过我和布莱克不会同时接拍电影。所以当她准备好回去拍戏时，我就会退居幕后，然后，你知道的，我们轮流来。你们俩轮流来。对。她去拍电影，我就，你知道的，在片场陪着她，和孩子们在一起。
is important to me. I, you know, I'm able to kind of get through, you know, but then Blake and I don't do movies at the same time. So she's ready to go back and do some, so I'll step down and then, you know, we'll, we go back and forth. You guys alternate. Yeah. She'll do a film and I'll just be, you know, with her on location, hanging with the kids.
你拍外景的时候总是把孩子们带在身边吗？总是带着。对。我们从来没有……但现在他们分别六岁、四岁和一岁。所以他们都在上学了。所以我们其实不能。对。
You take the kids with you on location always? Always. Yeah. We never have. But now they're six, four and one. So they're in school. So we can't really. Right.
离开。对。情况开始改变了。对。而且你，对，你会开始觉得，你必须根据——有孩子的各位到处都知道——你必须根据最适合你家庭的方式来做决定。我爸也有这种哲学，就是无论去哪儿都把我带上。哦，等等。
Leave. Yeah. It starts to change. Yeah. And you, yeah, you start to say, like, you have to make decisions based on, and people know everywhere who have kids that you make decisions based on what works for your family. My dad had the, my dad had the same philosophy around, take me with them wherever he go. Oh, wait.
不，我开玩笑的。没问题。杰森，我知道你有两个孩子。威尔，你有三个。三个。所以你有三个男孩。肖恩，你有吗？一条狗。
No, I'm kidding. That's no problem. Jason, I know you have two kids. Will, you have three. Three. So you have three boys. Shawn, do you have? One dog.
一条狗。好吧。所以。是的。你们以前，我的意思是，我从来没想过会有三个。听起来好像……三个男孩。
One dog. Okay. So. Yes. Yeah. Did you guys ever, I mean, I don't, I never imagined to have three. That sounds like that. Three boys.
但我有三个，他们分别是12岁、10岁和1岁。我的小儿子刚刚满一岁，对，你知道的，这改变了一切，因为一切都听从他们的指挥。一切都从那里开始。那是你的基准线。所以，一切都要看怎么做才对孩子们最好。全都是这样。你住哪儿，你做什么，你接什么工作，你什么时候度假，全都是为了这个。
But I have 10, there are 12, 10 and one. My youngest just turned one and yeah, it's, you know, it changes everything because everything is dictated. Everything starts there. That's your baseline. So it's, it's what works for the kids. It's everything. It's where you live, what you do, what jobs you take, what, when you take holidays, it's
但我有10个，这里有12个、10个和一个。我最小的孩子刚满一岁，对，这真的是……你知道的，这改变了一切，因为一切都是由它决定的。一切都从那里开始。那是你的基准线。所以，这……这取决于什么对孩子们合适。这就是一切。它决定了你住在哪里、做什么工作、接受什么工作、什么时候休假，它就是
all geared around. But how, how different is three from to the jump from two to three? I just like, I was researching like a blowtorch vasectomy after the third. I was like, there must be a way to stop. Oh, I know a way to stop this. Yeah. No, I've, I've thought about it without getting, yeah, with, yes, I've also had that same thought.
全都围绕着这个。但是，从两个孩子跳到三个孩子，区别有多大？我当时就觉得，我甚至在查第三个孩子出生后怎么做输精管切扎手术。我心想，总得有个办法能停下来。哦，我知道有个办法可以停下这个。对。不，我——我考虑过，不用，是的，我也想过同样的问题。
Um, but then I also think like, why, who am I to deprive the world, uh, of more of what just me. Yeah. Well, just hear me out. You guys. Look, this, this shit is no fucking fluke, you know, so why would I, why would I, but it is hard. I do, I do think that though, sometimes when, when somebody I love it, admire doesn't ever
呃，但转念一想，我又觉得，凭什么，我凭什么剥夺这个世界更多像我这样的人。对。好吧，听我解释，伙计们。听着，这他妈绝对不是侥幸，你知道，所以我为什么要——我为什么要——但这确实很难。不过我有时也确实会这么想，每当我看到一个我爱和敬佩的人从来不
have kids, I think, oh, those, those amazing genes aren't well, thank you. Let me tell you something though. Thank you. You're welcome. I think that the reason why, uh, one of the reasons why I don't have kids is because of some of these conversations that I've always been around, which is like, ugh, so tired. Oh, kids.
要孩子的时候，我会想，哦，那些——那些优秀的基因——噢，谢谢。不过我得跟你说点事。谢谢。不客气。我觉得我之所以——我不要孩子的原因之一，是因为我从小到大总是听到这种对话，比如，唉，好累啊。噢，孩子们。
Oh, I have to figure it out. And so growing up, I was like, well, maybe there's something to that. Maybe it is true. The first year is garbage. Okay. Everybody. First year is tough. But I gotta say though, there's never a moment where you're actually genuinely regretting
噢，我得想办法搞定。所以我在成长过程中就想，好吧，这也许是有道理的。也许真是这样。第一年简直是垃圾。好吧。各位。第一年太难熬了。但我必须说，从来没有哪一个时刻，你会真正地、由衷地感到
it. Never. I mean, it's the best. No, of course not. You can't imagine not. I can't remember not having kids now. Right. I will say, I will say as a man who's 51 and had a child at 50, I was like, hey guy,
后悔。绝不。我的意思是，这太棒了。不，当然没有。你无法想象没有他们的生活。现在我都想不出没有孩子的生活是什么样的了。没错。我得说，我得说作为一个51岁、在50岁才生了孩子的男人，我当时就想，嘿，老兄，
what the fuck were you doing? Hey guy, are you stupid? Yeah. And, uh, you were out. You were out of the game and you threw yourself back in there. And guess what? Your chassis is not holding up. Chassis.
你他妈在搞什么鬼？嘿，老兄，你傻了吗？是的。而且，你都已经退圈了，结果又把自己给塞回去了。你猜怎么着？你的身子骨可撑不住了。身子骨。
So close. I hate when you say that word. You know, I said this Ryan before on the, on the podcast, but I read this quote a long time ago that I said from this woman who said, I'd rather regret not having kids than have them and regret it later. And that was kind of my philosophy. No. Well, you got to consider the source.
太接近了。我讨厌你说这个词。瑞安，你知道我之前在播客里说过这个，但我很久以前读过一句话，是一个女人说的，她说：“我宁愿后悔没有孩子，也不愿生了他们以后再后悔。”这差不多就是我的座右铭。不。好吧，你得看看这话是谁说的。
Who the fuck was she? You know what I mean? It's my mom. Oh, no. Just a brim full of flashy hate. Sean. No, I know, Sean. We've talked about it before a few times and you've, you've thrown that quote in my
她他妈到底是谁？你知道我的意思吗？那是我的妈妈。哦，不。简直充满了对闪光事物的厌恶，肖恩。不，我知道，肖恩。我们以前讨论过好几次了，你把那句话
face to make me feel bad a bunch of times. No, no. I've always wanted to want them. When, when is the last time you and Scottie talked about it though? I mean, probably like a couple of years ago, only us listening here two years ago. A couple of years ago. Will you guys talk about it again? Just, just take it up the flagpole again today over lunch or something.
甩到我脸上有好多次了，让我觉得很糟糕。不，不。我一直都想要孩子。不过，你和斯蒂迪上一次聊这个是什么时候？我的意思是，大概是几年前吧，只有我们这些听众在两年前听过。几年前。你们俩还会再聊这个吗？今天吃午饭的时候再把这事提上日程呗，或者别的什么。
Awesome. I gotta say. I know. I mean, come on. I want to make sure that I want to be there for them like my dad wasn't right. So that's why I know I would be like a great dad. I just make sure that I'm ready as somebody who's been friends with you for 20 years. I know that you would be so good at it.
太棒了。我得说。我知道。我是说，拜托。我想确保自己能像我父亲那样陪伴他们，对吧？所以这就是为什么我知道我会成为一个好父亲。我只是要确保自己准备好了。作为一个跟你做了20年朋友的人，我知道你会非常擅长这个的。
You and Scottie would be great. Oh my God. Sean. I'll take one of yours. Yes. I'll take the kid. Sean, listen, if it doesn't, if you don't like it, I'll take the kid. Cause I did always want three.
你和斯蒂迪会很棒的。天哪。肖恩。我抱走你的一个。行。我要那个孩子。肖恩，听着，如果不行，如果你不喜欢，我把那孩子抱走。因为我一直都想要三个。
Oh, this is a great deal. But I like the way like Ricky, Ricky's always, Gervais is always saying that, you know, there is that sort of pressure from people to like, why, why is the ultimate thing not to have kids and his things like maybe that's just not for us. We don't want, we don't share this and it's totally, totally valid. 100%. But you do get a great tax write off if you have a kid. Oh, it's just so that you know.
哦，这买卖真划算。但我喜欢瑞奇——瑞奇·热维斯总是说的那种观点，你知道的，人们总是施加那种压力，问为什么人生终极目标不是生孩子，而他的看法是，也许那根本不适合我们。我们不想要，我们没有这种共鸣，这完全、完全是合理的。100%。但如果你生个孩子，你可以享受大笔的税务减免。哦，只是让你知道一声。
Ryan, we have, we have really, we, we've really monopolized your time and you've got three kids. Hold on, hold on. I'm not ready yet. I'm not ready yet. Okay. You want to ask you each one thing. Cause you guys are all people that I lesser in greater extents.
瑞安，我们把你的时间占用了太多，你还有三个孩子。等等，等等。我还没准备好呢。我还没准备好呢。好吧。我想问你们每人一个问题。因为你们都是我或多或少
Think less of now. Yeah. Worship. I love you guys so much. I love your work. What is your most fulfilling job that you've ever had? This is the one that you look back on, it doesn't have to be in showbizy. Sean, you go first.
现在有点看不起的人。对。崇拜。我太爱你们了。我爱你们的作品。你经历过的最让你有成就感的工作是什么？这是那种你回想起来的工作，不一定非得是娱乐圈的。肖恩，你先来。
Well, the most fulfilling job I've ever had is probably willing grace, of course. I mean, that happens to be the biggest job I've ever had too, but bird in flight on that. Oh, thanks. Uh, but speaking of anxiety, a lot of people thought, you know, you know, I came in like a ferret on cocaine all the time as that character. And I think it's because it's because of my anxiety because a lot of people like, oh, you're so funny.
好吧，我经历过的最有成就感的工作大概是《威尔与格蕾丝》，当然了。我的意思是，那恰好也是我接过的最大的一部作品，不过话说回来，还有《飞鸟》。哦，谢谢。呃，不过说到焦虑，很多人以为，你知道的，我扮演那个角色时，就像一只嗑了药的雪貂一样时刻亢奋，我想那是因为——是因为我的焦虑，因为很多人说，哦，你太搞笑了。
You have so much energy. You have so much anxiety. And I put it into the character. So I was like, ah. But since the day you like burst through that door on the second, literally see you bursting through that door on that set, it's just, it was, I just said, I mean, it's like seeing a bird in flight. Well, thanks.
你有那么多精力。你有那么多焦虑。而我都把它倾注到角色里了，所以我当时就想，啊。但自从你那天冲进片场的那扇门，字面意义上看到你冲进那个片场的大门，那种感觉，我就觉得，我的意思是，这就像看到一只在天空中飞翔的鸟。好吧，谢谢。
I think that guy's meant to do this. Yes. Well, that was my, she answered your question. Thank you for asking. It's very kind. Yes. Probably that job. It happens to be the biggest one, but also just because of the ancillary effect that's
我觉得这伙计天生就是干这个的。是的。好吧，那就是我的，她回答了你的问题。谢谢你提问。太客气了。是的。大概就是那份工作。它恰好是最大的一部，但也因为这在世界上产生了附属效应，这是无法预料的，没有人能预见到这一点。这是我们所做的事情带来的一种不可思议的副产品。所以这就是我的答案。太棒了。杰森。
had on the world, which was not, nobody could see that coming. It was just an incredible byproduct of what we were doing. So that's my answer. Amazing. Jason. I would say, I don't know, I'm really deeply, deeply, deeply in love with directing right now. And so I would say the first film that I directed, Bad Words, was probably really exciting for
我会说，我不知道，我现在对导演工作爱得深沉、深沉、深沉。所以我要说，我执导的第一部电影《脏话》，可能真的让我感到非常兴奋。
me. Shot by Kenseng. Kenseng. One of the most pretty looking, funniest, charming fucking movies. I love it. Will Arnett. I would say Arrested Development for me because I've said this before, it's very rare where you guys know when you have, when you're working on something and it doesn't feel like work,
由肯森拍摄。肯森。画面最漂亮、最搞笑、最迷人的他妈的电影之一。我太喜欢了。威尔·阿奈特。我会说对我来说是《发展受阻》，因为我以前说过，这种情况非常罕见：你知道自己在做某件事，而且工作时感觉不像是在工作，
I remember walking up, driving up every day to the lot on Fox and putting my pass on the thing and they opened up the gate and thinking, I'm so glad I'm here today. This is exactly where I want to be. I can't wait to get in. I never had anxiety about doing scenes and never had anxiety about any of it. I just couldn't wait for them to start rolling and start fucking around. I was like, I'm getting paid to, I've also said this on the show before once, I remember saying when I bought a nice place and saying to my dad, can you believe that fucking around?
我还记得每天开车去福克斯片场的停车场，把通行证放在感应器上，然后大门打开，心里想着，我太高兴我今天能来这里了。这正是我想要待的地方。我迫不及待地想进去。我对拍戏从来没有过焦虑，对其中的任何事情都没有过焦虑。我只盼着他们快点开机，然后开始瞎胡闹。我当时想，我居然能拿薪水——我也在节目里说过一次，我记得当我买了一处不错的房子时，我对爸爸说，你敢相信瞎胡闹也能赚钱吗？
Because he obviously thought I just fucked around my whole life. And I was like, turns out fucking around paid off. But it was truly such an amazing experience and it was very, you know, it was so fulfilling and there were so many great relationships and it was seamless and, you know, Jason and I, that's where we, that's where I met my little angel first fluttered into my life, Jason. And it's been a lifelong, yeah, the rest of it. I love you, Will.
因为他显然以为我一辈子都在瞎胡闹。我当时就想，事实证明，瞎胡闹真的有回报。但这真的是一次非常了不起的经历，而且非常，你知道的，非常有成就感，里面有那么多美妙的关系，一切都是那么顺理成章，而且，你知道的，杰森和我，我们就是在那里——那就是我的小天使第一次扑闪着翅膀飞进我生命中的地方，杰森。这是一段长久的，是的，余下的时光。我爱你，威尔。
Will. I love you. I love you. I love you too. Right. Your, your greatest, was it two girls and a guy? Two guys and a girl. Two girls and a girl.
威尔。我爱你。我爱你。我也爱你。瑞安。你最棒的，是《两个女孩和一个男主角》吗？《两个男人和一个女孩》。两个女孩和一个女孩。
Oh my God. The show, the show, the show, the show. The show. The show. The show. The show. The show. Oh God.
噢，天哪。那个节目，那个节目，那个节目，那个节目。那个节目。那个节目。那个节目。那个节目。天哪。
I don't know. I loved, I did love doing a sick. I love two guys, a girl and a pizza. But I remember, I kind of like, I worked with this guy named Danny Jacobson, who was the executive producer and writer. And I remember he came out and yelled at me one day because I was kind of holding back. I don't know if Will, if you can, you know, relate to this, but it was, you know, I felt, I was very Canadian on stage.
我不知道。我喜欢，我确实很喜欢演情景喜剧。我喜欢《两个男人、一个女孩和比萨店》。但我记得，我有点像——我和一个叫丹尼·雅各布森的家伙合作过，他是执行制片人和编剧。我记得有一天他出来对我大吼大叫，因为我当时有点放不开。我不知道威尔，你能不能对此产生共鸣，但当时，你知道的，我觉得我在舞台上非常加拿大。
I was very like, oh, I got to make sure I'm not too much. I'll give, you know, these other guys, I want to make sure everyone has their moment, you know. Just like, hey man, fucking take the stage. You take the stage, take it. It's yours. It doesn't make, diminish anybody else's performance. Just fucking go out there and give it your all.
我非常像那种，哦，我得确保自己表现得不太过分。我要给，你知道的，给这些其他人，我想确保每个人都有自己的高光时刻，你知道的。他就说，嘿，老兄，他妈的掌控舞台。你掌控舞台，去掌控它。它是你的。这不会削弱任何其他人表演的光彩。你他妈就上台去，全力以赴。
And it really stuck with me. Take the stage, take the stage. I still think about that. But I would say that my most fulfilling job was probably Deadpool 1 and 2, just because like, it almost killed me. I mean, it was like a, you know, it was chewing and blowing bubbles with every aspect of it. You remember you talking about that years earlier and wanting to really be respectful and deliberate about how and when you, you do that.
这真的深深地触动了我。掌控舞台，掌控舞台。我至今还在想这件事。但我要说，我最有成就感的工作大概是《死侍1》和《2》，只是因为——它差点把我折腾死。我的意思是，那就像是，你知道的，每一个环节都在嚼着口香糖吹泡泡。你还记得你几年前谈过这个，并且想要在如何以及何时进行这件事上做到真正尊重和慎重。
You know. There was a learn so much, you know, just like being involved in the guts of a big movie line. It wasn't a big movie. We shot it on nothing, but it was still. From the outside, it seems like that was a, that was a, a part in a movie and a thing that really was probably shifted everything for you. I can see how it, it was huge.
你知道的。学到了很多东西，你知道的，就像是参与了一部大制作电影的核心。虽然这不是一部大电影。我们是在一无所有的情况下拍出来的，但它依然。从外人看来，这似乎是电影里的一个角色和一件事，它真的可能为你改变了一切。我能看出它有多么巨大。
And that genre too. But it wasn't just a huge hit. You were really good in it. It was really funny. It used everything that you're good at. And look, you mentioned Canadian, you're from Vancouver, do you still, do you consider yourself Canadian? Oh, big time.
而且那种类型也是。但这不仅仅是一个巨大的热门。你在里面演得真的很好。非常搞笑。它用到了你擅长的所有东西。听着，你提到了加拿大，你是温哥华本地人，你现在还——你还认为自己是加拿大人吗？哦，当然算。
Being from Vancouver. Big time. I really do. It still counts. So British Columbia counts. That's what I mean. Despite this tricky two country name. Yes.
来自温哥华。当然算。我真的是。这依然算数。所以不列颠哥伦比亚省算数。这就是我的意思。尽管这个国家名字叫得有点别扭。是的。
It's, it is Canadian. Are you close to, I'm obviously joking, but do you, are you, do you still feel connected to your Canadian roots? I really do because I feel like Canada is like one of my parents in a way. It taught me to laugh at myself. It taught me to really kind of, you never take myself, I mean, it's one of the lines of Van Wilder. Don't take life too seriously.
这确实、确实是加拿大的。你跟——我当然是在开玩笑，但你跟——你还觉得自己跟自己的加拿大之根有联系吗？我真的有，因为我觉得加拿大在某种程度上就像我的父母之一。它教会了我嘲笑自己。它教会了我真正地，你永远不要把自己当回事——我的意思是，这是《留级之王》里的台词之一。别把生活看得太严肃。
You'll never get out alive. Yeah. But what is that? What is that? Will, you tell the story about the lobsters. It's, it's a, it's a tricky spot. How does that go again? I told, when Tina was on, I said the Canadian lobster fisherman and the American lobster
反正你也活不到活着离开。是的。但那是什么？那是什么？威尔，你讲讲那个龙虾的故事。这是一个——这是一个棘手的地方。那笑话是怎么说的来着？我讲过，当蒂娜来的时候，我说加拿大龙虾渔夫和美国龙虾
fisherman walking down the road and one, the American says, aren't you, you got, notice you don't have a lid on your lobster pot there by, aren't you worried about your lobsters getting out? And the Canadian says, no, these are Canadian lobsters. And I'm trying to get out. The other ones will pull them back down. And I will say like that's Canada. I caught the new fee accent there though, the new, pretty good, right?
渔夫在路上走着，其中一个美国人说，咦，我注意到你的龙虾篓上没有盖子啊，难道你不担心你的龙虾跑出来吗？然后那个加拿大人说，不，这是加拿大龙虾。我正想往外爬，其他的就会把它们给拉下去。不过我得说，我刚才抓到纽芬兰口音了，学得挺像的吧？
Yeah. Thanks everybody. Thanks everybody. I have to apologize to the people at Prince Edward Island cause they made a joke on Colbert and I just want them to know they're loved and we really love you on the PEI, all four listeners to the smart list podcast and they're like, what? We didn't know and shut up and we don't follow what you say, dude. You know, Ryan, you and I ought to do a tour of Canada, just like a, just like a coming
对。谢谢大家。谢谢大家。我得向爱德华王子岛的人们道歉，因为我在科尔伯特节目里开了一个玩笑，我只想让他们知道他们被爱着，我们在爱德华王子岛真的很爱你们，智能清单播客仅有的全部四个听众，他们就像是，什么？我们不知道，闭嘴吧，我们才不关注你说的那些呢，老兄。你知道的，瑞安，你和我应该去加拿大进行一次巡演，就像是一次——就像是一次衣锦还乡之旅，我们还要搞个游行。绝对的。上车吧。
home tour and we'll just like a parade. Absolutely. Let's get in the car. Yeah. Let's get in Sean's Toyota Corolla and see how far we can get before my Nissan Centra takes over. Let's do it. Let's do a tour of Canada and just a victory lap in Sean's car.
走吧。坐上肖恩的丰田花冠，看看在我的日产阳光接管之前我们能开多远。走吧。去加拿大巡演，在肖恩的车里享受一下胜利的喜悦。你们要上那边去。你们要把播客带到那里去。我们要去那里巡演。
You guys are going up there. You guys are taking the podcast there. We're doing the tour up there. Yeah. I know more about this fucking show than you three. I know you do. Rob Bennett and I have been working this shit behind the scenes, like no one's business. Ryan Reynolds, you are a man, a myth.
对。我对这个他妈节目的了解比你们三个加起来还多。我知道你了解。罗伯·贝内特和我一直在幕后疯狂地搞这些事情。瑞安·雷诺兹，你是一个传奇人物，一个神话。
You're a prince. And I can't thank you enough for doing this. Love you. Love you like crazy. Love you guys too. Thank you for having me. This has been, this was amazing for me. It's been awesome having you.
你是一个王子。我太感谢你来做这个了。爱你。爱死你了。我也爱你们。谢谢你们邀请我。这对我来说——这对我来说太棒了。你能来太棒了。
Thank you, Ryan. You're the best. Thanks guys. And I never say that. No, you don't. He doesn't. I never heard him say that. No.
谢谢你，瑞安。你最棒了。谢谢你们。我可从来不说这话。不，你才不说呢。他不。我从没听他说过这话。不。
That's how. Thanks guys. Take it easy. Have a great rest of the day. Bye, Ryan. Bye, guys. God, I really like that, Ryan. Really, all you Canadians are so nice.
就是这样。谢谢你们。保重。祝你们余下的时光过得愉快。再见，瑞安。再见，伙计们。天哪，我真的很喜欢那个，瑞安。真的，你们所有加拿大人都太友善了。
Why is that? When does it get dark? Is there, it's going to be like a series of... Like September through April. Oh, oh. It gets real dark. Does that coincide with hockey season or the opposite? Yeah.
这是为什么？天黑得有多早？是不是有一系列…… 从九月一直持续到四月。哦，哦。天黑得真快。这跟冰球赛季是同步的还是相反的？对。
Well, if it wasn't for hockey, forget it. It does get dark up there in the north, but you know what? The flip side is it gets really light. It does seem though, like every, because I don't know Canada like you do, obviously, but it does seem like everybody that is in the business of show is always so grateful and upbeat and kind. Yeah. There's no entitlement, which is...
好吧，要不是因为冰球，那就别提了。北方天黑得确实很早，但你知道吗？另一方面，天也亮得很早。不过，看起来好像每个——因为我不像你那么了解加拿大，显然，但似乎每个从事演艺行业的人总是那么感恩、乐观和善良。对。没有那种理所当然的特权感，也就是——
Yeah. Well, no. I mean, we're so excited. I was talking to, you know, Sean and I, we were talking to Andrea Martin the other day, you know, who's, who lived in Canada for a long time and she's actually American, the brilliant Andrea Martin. And I was saying that, like, you know, growing up in Canada, I moved down here because I knew that there was so much more opportunity down here and same reason, I'm sure that
对。好吧，不。我是说，我们太兴奋了。我当时在跟——你知道的，肖恩和我，我们前几天在跟安德里亚·马丁聊天，你知道的，她在加拿大住了很长时间，她其实是个美国人，才华横溢的安德里亚·马丁。我当时就说，像，你知道的，在加拿大长大，我之所以搬到这里来，是因为我知道这里有更多更好的机会，同样的理由，我敢肯定
Ryan did. Like that you can, there's only so much that you can do it sort of. And Canada is such an amazing place. I knew so many, I mean, so many funny, talented, incredible people who are from Canada who moved here because it's just, there's just more, it's just bigger and more people. And you get down here and you're like, I don't know, I guess you just kind of appreciate that, like, that you get to do this. I'm a kid from Toronto.
瑞安也是。就像你可以，你能在某种程度上做的事情是有限的。加拿大是一个如此了不起的地方。我认识那么多——我是说，那么多才华横溢、来自加拿大、不可思议的有趣的人，他们之所以搬到这里来，是因为这里有更多的机会，而且这里更大，人更多。当你来到这里时，你会觉得，我不知道，我想你只是开始感激，你可以做这个。我是一个来自多伦多的孩子。
As much as I sort of joke, I'm just a guy who grew up in Toronto. I have no showbiz connections. But let me ask you something, Wilk, because when you came down and when you guys come down to this country, because on the outside, for me, it always seems like, well, because we live here, all just the kind of like the turbulent, you know, atmosphere that is now in the country that divides, you know, just turn on the news and all this stuff is happening. And it seems like from the outside, Canada doesn't have them, I'm sure you do. But on the outside, it just seems like Canada's just up, everybody's upbeat and happy and
尽管我有点开玩笑，但我只是一个在多伦多长大的普通人。我没有任何娱乐圈的关系。但我要问你个问题，威尔，因为当你来到这里，当你们来到这个国家时，因为从外表来看，对我来说，总是觉得，好吧，因为我们住在这里，所有那种动荡的——你知道的——现在这个国家存在的导致分裂的氛围，你知道的，只要打开新闻，所有这些事情都在发生。而从外表看起来，加拿大好像没有这些，我确信你们是有的。但从外表来看，加拿大似乎一切都很好，每个人都乐观、快乐、
like good spirited. No, I think there are a lot of issues, of course, anywhere you go. There are issues that are sort of germane to whatever place you go to and Canada has its own issues as well. But there is a sense of like, you know, I don't know if it's the kind of a hangover from the sort of the English, like sort of a Commonwealth thing, which is just kind of, you know, keep calm and carry on idea of just like, yeah, shit happens. And you just kind of keep going and you, and you just don't, it's one of the things that
而且精神饱满。不，我觉得有很多问题，当然，无论你去哪里都有。有些问题是特定于你去的任何地方的，加拿大也有它自己的问题。但有一种感觉，你知道的，我不知道这是否是英国那种英联邦传统留下的某种“宿醉”，也就是那种，你知道的，“保持冷静，继续前行”的想法，就是，是的，糟心事总是会发生。你只要继续前行，而且你——而且你不会——这是我喜欢的事情之一，也是我有点想要反抗的事情之一，那就是：别把自己太当回事。
I love slash sort of push back against, which is like, don't take yourself too seriously. Yeah. Keep it in perspective, guy. And Ryan embodies that. Ryan embodies all that. Is Jason frozen or is he asleep? Oh, it looks like. This fucking conversation is just putting me to sleep.
是的。放平心态，老兄。而瑞安完美地体现了这一点。瑞安体现了所有这些。杰森是死机了还是睡着了？哦，看起来是的。这个他妈的对话简直快把我催眠了。
Holy shit. What the fuck are we talking about? Are we still on Canada? Holy shit. I was, I asked the question because Ryan seems to embody everything that Will is saying. Ryan is all of those things. Oh my God. You can't believe that you're continuing.
卧槽。我们他妈的在聊什么呢？我们还在聊加拿大吗？卧槽。我——我问那个问题是因为瑞安似乎体现了威尔所说的一切。瑞安就是所有这些。天哪。真不敢相信你还在继续。
You know, we're recording, right? Guys, we're supposed to be wrapping up the Ryan episode. What do you want to say? I literally thought it was frozen. What do you want to say about Ryan? It was a finite number of minutes in my day to enjoy. Fuck. Boy, you were really off somewhere, Jason.
你知道我们在录音吧，对吧？伙计们，我们本来应该结束瑞安这一集的。你想说什么？我刚才真的以为他死机了。你想对瑞安说什么？我今天能享受的时光只有那么几分钟。操。老兄，你刚才真的神游天外了，杰森。
He looked like he was fucking frozen. Like we were at the Madame Tussauds and here's the Jason Bateman. It's what shock looks like. So listen, this guy, Ryan Reynolds, just a stunning man, a great friend, an incredible talent. Is he getting more talented? Does it seem like it? I think so.
他看起来就像他妈的死机了一样。就像我们在杜莎夫人蜡像馆参观杰森·贝特曼蜡像一样。这就是震惊的表情。所以听着，这家伙，瑞安·雷诺兹，简直是个惊艳的男人，一个伟大的朋友，一个不可思议的天才。他是不是越来越有才了？看起来是这样吗？我想是的。
Yeah. I mean, he understands, I guess, you know, what his thing is and he's like fine-tuning and fine-tuning and then putting it in other areas and, you know, fucking slinging booze and buying. He didn't even get to his mobile phone company that he owns. I know. He owns a fucking mobile phone company. Yeah.
是的。我的意思是，他懂得了，我猜，你知道的，他的专长是什么，他一直在精益求精，精益求精，然后把它运用到其他领域，你知道的，他妈的卖酒还买下——他甚至还没提到他拥有的那家手机公司呢。我知道。他他妈拥有一家手机公司。对。
And you know, when you call somebody through his cellular phone, you start in any conversation. No, no, no, no, no, no, you cannot end this right now. I don't even know what a telescope for. I could just see it coming right here. Go ahead. He starts the conversation by saying hi, but how do you end it? Oh, you say? Bye-bye.
而且你知道的，当你通过他的手机给别人打电话时，你一开始的对话是——不，不，不，不，不，不，你不能现在结束这个。我甚至不知道望远镜是干什么用的。我刚刚看到它朝这边来了。说吧。他开始对话时说的是嗨，但你怎么结束呢？哦，你说？拜拜。
Bye-bye. Smart. What. Smart. What. What. What. Smart.
拜拜。聪明。什么。聪明。什么。什么。什么。聪明。
What. What. What. What. What. What. What. What.
什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。什么。
What. What. What. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。